Hello, this is the first sentence!
Did you guys know that?
The other day it was Steinskate Day.
I should add tooturu.
An honor.
There was like a whole...
There was like a whole display...
Akihabara Don Quijote and everything.
Saw it on Twitter?
Yeah, yeah.
There was like pictures and stuff.
They decorated...
If you know the Akihabara Don Quijote.
How there's like the pictures on the sides of the escalator when you go up.
They decorated it with Steinskate pictures and stuff.
Did you go?
I'm not in Japan.
Yeah, they made it an official day.
The Steinskate.
Is the cafe still going?
The maid cafe?
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
And Bunny Day.
Bunny Day was...
Yesterday?
I think...
Quite disappointed.
I saw like...
Barely any bunny girls on my feed.
I think I...
My...
My Twitter is...
Broke.
It's okay.
I saw no bunny girls.
Like one.
That's it.
Unacceptable.
I know.
How?
I don't know.
Actually, maybe I wasn't also on Twitter very much.
Can't believe you are willing to endanger your whole PC integrity just to entertain us.
I don't think these are...
Mal?
They might be mining crypto.
But I think...
But I...
I don't think they're gonna give me a virus.
Bunny suit...
When?
Kind of want one.
I'm sure...
I haven't thought about...
What outfit to do after...
My next one.
So I don't know.
Only one way to find out.
Yeah!
Today we'll be playing YouTube games.
Wowie.
Have you guys ever played...
Okay.
Wait.
Raise your hand if you have played a YouTube game before.
The playables.
Raise your hand.
Oh, I did think about a pirate.
I'm not gonna lie.
No.
Never.
Once.
Happy International Friendship Day.
Bunny girl Minto would be so cute.
Rascal does not dream of...
Bunny girl Minto.
You've played multiple.
That checks out, Orca.
Famous last words.
I don't think they can be a virus.
Here's a donation to the...
They're literally...
I don't think...
YouTube would be shut down if these had viruses.
No?
You look like an animated sticker.
What would an...
What's an animated sticker face that I could...
Er...
Ehhh...
Undi...
Echi!
I see...
I want to kind of make a cat clock.
Actually, that was like... That was like some merch that I wanted to work on.
Was I want to make a cat clock?
Like, you know, the... The ones that the eyes go...
But with like that face?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Maybe one day.
And a moving tail.
I guess it would have to be...
My new...
Outfit with the tail.
Only if it screams death penalty as you are.
Right.
Okay, I'll stay.
I'll stay twin tail now.
Talisman, thank you so much for the vibe.
Thank you!
And...
Fluffy!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome back, everybody.
We'll...
Welcome back to...
Wait...
To...
Mem...
But, um...
Yeah, so we'll be playing these today.
I...
Look at all this.
We could strike gold in here.
There's attack hole.
There's solar smash.
This one I see all the time.
Tall man run.
What is dig deep?
Fashion battle?
Fork and sausage.
Oh!
I see ads for the color water sort!
Yes!
I see ads for games like...
These look like the ones that are like those mobile games that probably have a ton of ads.
And so these...
Parking Jam!
That's another one I've gotten ads for.
So these probably...
If they have...
If they don't have ads...
They're already...
Superior to...
Getting the app, no?
Or getting...
I like...
State.io Words of wonders!
Wait, I've seen this ad too!
Solar smash is genuinely so peak?
No way.
We're on your case soon, Mito!
Apparently, the original song artist saw your announcement...
I know!
Ayoban!
Saw...
Saw my tweet!
I'm kind of nervous.
Uh...
Nimmi...
Nimmi messaged me and she's like...
Do you want to...
So originally, I wasn't gonna...
Have it like...
Release...
For 400k...
But I was like...
I don't have anything for 400k...
So...
Maybe I could just release it for then...
Maybe it'll motivate people to subscribe...
Subscribe!
And um...
And uh...
So I like...
Like...
And then Nimmi messaged me and she's like...
Do you want to do a countdown stream together?
So...
Um...
Probably...
Do that...
Eventually...
Though...
I...
I kind of worry about the music video...
Um...
I thought it would be...
Done sooner...
But it might be done a little bit later...
So I apologize...
I got ahead of...
I got ahead of myself...
I think...
Um...
But...
Should be out...
Soon TM!
I fear...
Many of my things have been...
Delayed lately...
I...
I'm so sorry...
You guys...
I'm sorry...
Um...
Yeah...
My outfit was supposed to be done around this time...
Music video was supposed to be done around this time...
Uh...
Sorry...
Everybody I'm working with has been busy...
But also...
I...
Had to delay the...
Cover...
Because of my voice too...
It was...
The...
All the animation and everything for...
Or like the art and everything for it...
Was done...
Back in May...
I've been planning this for a really long time...
Like since...
Since...
Since I heard the song...
The...
Song...
I was like...
I wanna do this...
Cover...
And then I was like...
It would be good...
Of course I was like...
Wait...
Nimi's voice is like an angel...
So...
Yeah...
Mm-mm-mm-mm...
And then I...
I decided...
Enjoy goals!
Thank you so much for the tiny gift!
Thank you!
I'm not upset because I know what you are...
Trying your best...
Oh...
I was like...
What am I?
I am a green woman...
Sorry for what...
Our daddy taught us...
Not to be ashamed of our meantime...
I'm a green female...
So true...
Yeah...
So...
But...
It...
Looks so good so far...
You guys...
Oh my gosh...
I'm so excited...
I know I keep like...
Posting...
So good...
And we sound so good...
And I'm just...
I've just been so...
So excited about it...
So...
It's been a long time since I've been like...
This excited about a cover...
So I'm like...
Yee...
Ha ha ha ha...
Thank you for playing my favorite games...
On my birthday...
Wow...
Wait...
What do you mean...
Your favorite games...
Also see Slick...
Happy Birthday...
I hope I said her name right...
Speaking of Ayoban...
Did you hear their Unwelcome School remix...
When was the last time you did a collab cover?
I guess...
Maybe...
Hanamori...
Back in the day?
There was a...
What was that song?
Kamino...
Oh...
Maybe...
Last year with...
Oh, what was that song?
Did she upload that?
The Steven Universe one...
I guess that one, maybe...
Kami no Mani Mani...
Yeah, yeah...
I guess maybe that one...
Does Herb count?
Well, that was...
That was just...
Karaoke...
Sorry, Mint...
I have...
I have always seen mint and turquoise as blue colors...
But it's mint green...
Specific...
Mint green...
I like how people mention the Liz collab, but...
Nerissa...
Iron Mouse...
There were several people there that day too...
Everybody just remember it...
But I don't blame you guys...
Elizabeth's...
Version of that song was so good...
Die with a Smile...
Just so good...
Mmm...
It was so, so good...
Yeah...
Speaking of Elizabeth...
She had her 3D debut...
Yeah...
Herb had her 3D debut...
It was so cute...
I watched it...
I watched Gigi's last night too...
And everybody is all...
I think everybody is on the same page...
I was like...
What was that?
There's Angry Birds on here!
Shut up!
Wait...
There's legit stuff in here!
No way!
But also...
I have been recording some other things...
Pac-Man!
What the hell is foot, Chinko?
Wizard Oji-chan...
I liked...
That...
Cover they did together...
It was so cute...
Actually...
It was actually so cute...
Yeah...
A very Gigi...
Debut...
I'm sure everybody can agree...
What else is in here?
I don't even know what to start...
Why...
Wait...
There's flappy foot...
You couldn't be the angel...
Because you couldn't convincingly...
Convincingly chat...
Birth...
After that end prank...
Chat...
Oh, rant...
That's also partially why...
I...
Didn't wanna be...
Okay, so...
I don't wanna say the name of the song...
Just...
Just because I feel like it's too...
Like I've already...
People...
Might already know...
But I don't wanna say...
Because I feel like it'll...
Even though so much has already been given away...
I feel like it just gives it away too much...
But...
In the song...
The angel...
Is a little more devilish than the devil...
And the devil is a little more like...
Not as devilish as she should be...
You know what I mean?
So...
I thought that it kind of...
Also matched our personalities...
Hmm...
Where Nimi is...
So...
You know...
She's like an angel...
But also...
Oh my gosh...
There's one part of...
Oh...
She sounds so good...
I can't wait for you guys to hear it...
She sounds...
She sounds so good...
She sounds so...
So good...
I'm...
A medium fan...
Can you do grave robbing ASMR for 444K subs?
Okay...
I'm writing it down...
Why...
Why am I grave robbing them?
Grave...
Robbing...
ASMR...
444K...
Okay...
My friend Big Bunny said...
Play Tall Man Run...
Okay...
We'll start with Tall Man...
I've been dreaming about you doing that cover...
It's insane...
Now one day I woke up and it was real...
Yeah...
Does YouTube games have Elsa Pregnant Foot Doctor or any...
Elsa...
I didn't see any Elsa...
Elsa things...
I think Disney would be like...
Nothing even remotely looking like Elsa...
Though we have Bill the Queen...
So...
Yeah...
I got jumpscared by my art in your thumbnail...
Thank you for the...
Yay!
Thank you for the cute art!
Thank you!
It's so cute!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright...
Tall Man Run, shall we start?
Okay, wait...
Does this have BGM?
No?
I guess I'll keep my BGM...
Oh, he's so skinny!
Would you go out on a date with me at 500k subs?
Where are we going?
Mr. Matt Johnson?
Where?
Skinny man run...
Denny's?
They actually look like the ads...
Is this like an ad game?
You know what?
I keep getting ads for this one...
It's called like...
It's like some...
Oh gosh, what's it called?
Like Girl Runner...
Or something...
And it's like...
This...
Blonde, twin-tailed girl...
That like...
Shoots zombies...
Is...
I keep getting ads for that...
And...
Oh...
I kind of wish that it was on here...
Goddess Run!
Yes!
Oh my gosh...
Oh, it's you knew it...
Question...
Do you like cheese?
Because you're pretty...
Cheese...
Yourself?
Huh?
I'm pretty cheese?
If you play the Elsa foot baby doctor games...
I'll have to leave...
There are none!
Go to Akihabara!
I'll think about it...
We could maybe do a date to Akihabara at 500k...
But that's a long time from now, so...
Run!
Sure!
Ghost!
Definitely...
The TikTok reddit mindless odd games...
Yeah!
Wait, we might...
We might strike gold here though...
We'll see...
Okay, here we go...
I'm playing...
Whoa!
Oh, he's expanding!
I'm going plus 50...
Oh, wow...
Wait...
Keep going...
Why is he...
Oh my god...
It's so loud...
No!
Why is he so...
Why is he...
He's not...
He's supposed to be tall...
But he's just like...
Thick!
Oh my god...
It's so loud!
Please!
I died!
Wait...
It's so loud...
Hold on...
Oh my god...
I can't...
It's so...
It's so
loud...
Okay, hold on...
Actually...
I'm just gonna turn off the sound effects...
Let's just do that...
Okay, sorry about that everybody...
Alright, let's...
Let's try again...
I wish I could be faster...
Oh, I could be plus...
What?
Is this...
Oh...
Wait...
This is how wide I am...
And this is how tall...
I'm...
Wow!
I'm a...
I'm a hot dog...
Oh no!
I'm not gonna make it!
What?
I don't...
What the hell is this?
How am I supposed to make it through here?
I die every time!
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, I'm supposed to be big enough to get through, I think...
Maybe...
Oh, I completed it!
Okay...
Okay, here we go...
Alright...
Let's go...
Plus 100 up...
What?
This is horrible...
I guess he is tall, man...
Wait, I wanna be taller...
Yeah...
And wide...
I look like a wiener dog...
Explaining the joke...
Japanese for small...
Wait, did I make...
Level 3?
Let's go...
Okay, now we're...
Alright, let's go...
I'm so...
Slow...
Whoa...
Sick...
Flip, man...
Whoa...
Oh...
Oh my god...
I'm
so...
I'm so...
Ah...
This game sucks, you guys...
This game sucks...
Skinny legend...
I think I got the max score...
I think I'm too good at this game...
Tall...
Taller...
Tallest...
Whoa...
It's like you're too...
Oh no, I'm too tall...
It's...
It's too slow...
For it to be like any...
Difficult...
You know...
It's like one of those mobile games...
Yeah...
Are you feeling it?
Are you feeling so like...
Did I make it?
Oh...
I actually completed...
Let's try and get to level 10...
This game inspired astrobot...
I get it...
I see the resemblance...
I wanna become as wide as possible...
Oh...
Here we go...
Alright...
Oh...
How do I become wider?
I like how they give you the option...
Like...
Do you only wanna be...
25...
Taller...
Or...
100 taller...
Eat more...
No...
Oh yeah...
It's like when you try to eat to grow...
I'm a growing girl still...
I can grow up...
Taller...
Probably...
If I got a little bit more ectoplasm in me...
Wait, I can double...
I can double...
Wait, there's men to fight here...
Wait, there's math?
Oh my god...
They're following me...
Times two...
Oh my god...
Wait...
Guys...
I don't think we're gonna make it...
Eat your vegetables...
I do...
I like how we just...
Die...
We just...
Who's that in the background?
Like is he a boss?
Like I can't...
Tell what's going on...
Tall...
Oh yeah...
Wide...
No down...
Oh no...
A little down...
No skinny...
Only thick...
Only big...
I wanna try...
Solar Smash...
I think you dropped something...
It's your copium...
What?
Ah...
No...
Yeah...
I caught some downvotes...
They're...
They're roasting me on Reddit...
Delicious content slop...
What do you mean?
These are free...
I don't have to pay for anything...
Thanks YouTube...
Oh wait...
We're almost two...
Wait...
Okay...
Next level...
We'll become as skinny as possible...
Okay...
This is...
Oh my god...
There's bombs!
Who left these here?
Next time we flop...
We're in our flop era...
Eating vegetables and drinking milk...
Won't make you taller...
You need...
To eat bones...
Yeah...
Wait...
What was it?
Recently...
That was somewhat obsessed with bones...
Oh, in Oblivion!
That's right!
I was like...
Wait a second...
We met someone recently...
That...
Really liked bones...
Okay, here we go...
Plus 50...
Plus 25...
Whoa...
Look how big we are...
Holy cow!
Wait...
Thicker...
Mine...
Oh my god...
Bigger...
Oh wait!
I didn't notice the jump!
Look
at his arms!
He can't even...
Wait...
So if I'm really tall...
Do I like get all this...
Stuff?
I can't...
Oh he has a boss!
I took him down!
Oh my god!
Okay...
Now we try to become as small as possible...
Alright guys...
Tiny...
Oh...
Don't...
Don't ever become too tiny...
You just...
You cease to exist!
You become a head!
And that's it!
Too bad!
Stick figure?
More like thick figure...
Oh yeah baby!
Let's try solar smash!
Get me out of this game...
Also prison life!
There's also city smash!
Okay, I'm gonna bring back the music...
If there is some...
I'm very hesitant...
I will turn it down...
Before I do so...
There has to be music in these games, no?
I say we do that to all tiny folks...
The children?
Is that how you died?
Okay...
Smash...
What do I planet smash?
Or system smash?
Let's go small...
This is our first time smashing...
This is our first smash...
Okay...
I'm moving...
Oh...
Expand weapon category...
I'm firing it on the planet!
Oh my god!
I'm just killing everything!
Goodbye Earth!
Can't forget Antarctica!
What else am I supposed to do here?
Come to Brazil they said...
There is no more Brazil...
There's no more anything...
My house!
Is this the game?
I'm...
I'm creating a meatball!
Kinda looks yummy though...
What is this, Hawaii?
Not anymore...
Meatball!
This is what happened to the dinosaurs...
Can you blast Ohio?
Already done, buddy!
You can hear the people...
Wait!
Oh!
Look at that!
It's becoming like...
A...
A ball!
I'm so
sorry...
Wait!
Can I blast through?
What's the downside?
Oh, wait!
Oh, whoops!
Poetry, Minto.
Sheer poetry.
Okay.
Alright.
Planet.
Change planet.
You have completed the...
What?
Oh, we can do multiple things!
Okay.
Let's send a...
A tentacle man.
Level nine tentacle.
What does it mean?
My
god!
Wait.
The wolves with lasers.
No!
Rip Florida!
Yeah, he did go right into Florida.
He's eating the inside out!
What is this one?
This one looks like the Ava angel.
Okay.
What?
Alright.
Why do they hate Earth so much?
Do your thing.
Oh, another one.
Just kidding.
Uh, what's this one?
We're sending more worms.
Oh, oh!
It's about to...
It's literally the Ava angel?
No kidding!
Where'd the...
Where'd the worm go?
Oh!
I'm summoning.
The worm.
Three billion are dead!
Whoa!
Oh, it just...
Took a chunk.
Holy!
That's a chunk!
That's a big ol' chunk!
What's the point of this game?
What's the point?
I feel like it's too easy.
Aliens.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait!
Now it's defending!
Wait, is it supposed to defend?
Wait, am I supposed to be destroying Earth?
Or...
Protecting it?
It all comes...
Tumbling down, tumbling down, tumbling down...
To nothing...
I want the dog back.
More dogs.
Only dogs.
What's the point of this game?
Nice.
There's still lights on.
Go dogs, go!
Go!
Holy cow!
Can you hit the moon?
Where is the moon?
Uh...
This Earth has...
Oh, there it is.
I don't think so.
It seems quite far, no?
No.
Let's try a different planet.
Let's go to...
Oops, sorry.
Oops.
There we go.
Let's go to...
Uranus.
Dogs!
More dogs!
More space dogs!
Actually, hold on.
Wait.
Let's do exactly what I did before.
What, does this drill?
Get in there.
Drill!
Why dogs, though?
Uh...
Cause...
That was an option.
Oh!
What's happening?
Well, they're spreading apart.
There it is!
There it goes.
Drilling.
Oh!
We get to join this one!
That's exciting.
Uh...
Wait!
I get to pilot it!
Wait, the dogs did barely any damage.
Did you see that?
This guy's actually digging, though.
But all the damage...
Is it, like, healing itself?
It is!
Look at that!
Oh, yeah.
It's all gas, isn't it?
Lucky you.
Okay.
Let's do...
Minky power drilling your anus.
My anus!
Nah.
You live another day.
Let's try prison life.
Super scent.
Never, never, never give up.
Okay.
I'm going to jail!
Oh!
Oh, God!
I'm getting my...
Help!
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Arrest.
Which one's me?
I'm an Alcatraz!
Oh, my God!
Alcatraz looks a little different than what I remember.
It's time to restore peace to this crime-infested place.
As the new prison warden...
I thought I was going to be in prison.
As the new prison warden, it is your duty to reform criminals and make this land a safer place.
Oh.
I'm going in.
I'm so slow.
Okay.
Oh, no!
It's one of these types of games.
Where, like, you get money.
And then it's like, okay.
This money goes here.
What's that white-out game that, like, I get ads for all the time?
Oh, it does say idle game.
You're right.
White-out survival.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That one, that one, that one.
Okay.
I get the money.
Did they pay me to go to prison?
Oh, he's crying.
No bed.
I wish I weren't so slow.
Yippee, jail!
Wait.
What am I doing here?
Oh, you.
Okay.
Are you reformed?
I'm taking his money.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Okay.
Come this way.
Criminal scum.
Oh, my God!
He's a free man!
This game is so slow.
Holy cow.
To quote your Oshi, Mike Staklasa.
Endless trash!
I take your money.
You pay me to come into jail, and you pay me to leave jail.
I fixed him.
I think I'm good at my job.
After taking multiple dogs and getting mercilessly drilled.
Uranus healed.
Okay, so we take this.
I think we can...
Oh, I can level up.
Alright, good.
Oh, no.
I'm afraid to click this.
Is it another ad?
It looks like you're stuck inside an ad game.
I am!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna click it.
But you guys can't see.
Just in case it opens something up, you know?
It just gave me...
Why wouldn't you click times two?
It just gave it to me for free.
Why wouldn't you click that?
The first hit is free.
Did you see the trailer for Spy Drops?
Looks like MGS but with the anime go...
What?
No, I haven't heard of that.
Okay, now you guys are going to dig.
Oh my god.
They're...
They're digging for...
Something.
Wait, I can't lose my prisoners though.
Because...
They will...
They...
I can't...
I can't lose them because...
I can't reform them.
They will...
They will not dig for me.
They yearn for the mines.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, come here.
Come here, yo.
I like how they go into jail once and then they're like...
Yeah, baby!
Oh, you want to go to the mines!
Okay.
Come here.
Minecraft.
He's so upset about it.
There's also aquapark.io.
I'm curious.
There's so many.
Okay, I'll be back for you guys.
Oh, we can get this guy.
We can buy someone.
Hire someone to do my job.
Oh, now we're...
Now we're cooking.
Oh yeah!
Sad man.
Come here.
Oh, you yearn for the mines.
You're not reformed at all.
How many people can go in here?
Oh, I guess three?
And there's a toilet.
Alright.
Get in there!
Criminal scam!
Guys, is this engaging?
Don't be asleep!
Let me take your money.
That guy's up.
That guy's killing that other man!
Wait a second!
What is he doing in there?
Actually.
What's going on?
I'm confused.
Can't you do anything?
Come on!
Okay.
I think I'm done with prison life.
It moves so slow.
Oh, now he's reformed!
Are you sure?
Oh, he's crying.
Are you sure you're reformed?
You were just trying to kill that guy.
He did the crime.
He did the time.
Come on.
Get out of here.
You're a big ol' crocodile too.
Wait, we're gonna level up.
Yippee!
You just get free money!
What's the...
Why wouldn't you...
No bed.
Why wouldn't you?
What's this?
Oh, I can pay to be...
Faster.
It didn't make a difference at all.
It
didn't make a difference at all!
Oh, he's doing it though!
He's doing the job!
Okay, come here.
You're free, you're free.
You're free.
And I'm taking my money...
On the way.
Give me my star.
Watashi wa star.
I like how they just leave their money...
In the jail cell and the criminals don't even take it.
No bed.
Oh, and he's also making me money!
Wait, this is a lucrative business, huh?
Huh?
This is pretty great.
Wait, what are you supposed to do?
Why are you...
Oh, you're supposed to go back into the jail cell?
Okay.
Why are they just leaving their money on the floor?
Go back in there.
Okay.
They yearn for the mines, but there's not enough rock.
There's just...
The earth is just not...
There's just not enough earth for them to mine.
There can only be one mine...
One Minecraft Steve.
Remember to always tip your prison warden.
Maybe this is like a restaurant, you know?
Wait, no, no.
What are you doing?
You're supposed to be mining.
You don't want to anymore?
You tired?
Minecraft Steve wouldn't get tired.
I'm just saying that.
Get back in here.
Crybaby.
Come here.
You yearn for the mines.
He tips me every time.
Go mine.
He's really doing it.
Themed prison restaurant.
I've been to one like that before.
There used to be a place in Shibuya...
That was like a prison themed restaurant.
And...
But the menu was like pretty icky.
But all the...
All the tables were jail cells.
And the...
The...
The servers...
They were dressed up as nurses.
J.S.R.
Welcome to Mambo Ship.
Yeah, I'm gonna get x2.
Oh my god!
They find...
They get to eat!
You can eat!
Wait, we can have more jail cells.
We're expanding!
There's so many more prisoners and they're just leaving their cash on the floor.
Come on, reformed one.
Let me take your money first.
Oh, I can take two guys now.
Look at all my cash money!
Still no bed.
Go guys!
Wait, what's over here?
Nothing.
Oh my god.
They're just actually sleeping like...
Standing up.
I feel bad.
What's my phrasing?
What did I say?
I'm sorry!
Wait, I can upgrade.
Please.
Capacity up.
Wait.
Worker.
Oh, okay.
When will I be faster, please?
Are you hungry?
Okay, come on.
You can eat.
As a treat.
Four people have this bookmarked, by the way.
Four people are really into...
Wait, now you don't want to eat?
You want to go to jail?
I mean...
Wait, you're in jail.
Sorry.
You want to go to Minecraft?
There you go.
Alright, back to your cell.
How is this an idle game?
I'm doing so much work.
They're not even singing, dancing for me.
It's a hidden gem.
It does feel like a Roblox game, huh?
Can't believe I showed up to the stream late as the only person who plays these games unironically.
Let's play another one.
Exit.
Wait, hold on.
I gotta get back to the...
Okay, here we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
What else do we have?
I mean, we have a million things here.
We have a bajillion games here.
They're all free.
They're free.
It's ad free.
Free free.
Draw Climber?
I see Drawing Carnival.
Don't play Prison Life idle game.
It sucks.
Draw...
Climber.
Try Sandwich.
Where the hell do you see Sandwich?
You don't wanna play Emoji Puzzle?
They have an unfinished port of Jetpack Joyride 2?
What?
Oh, I see it.
Draw Climber.
Okay.
You.
Draw.
Oh, okay.
Look at him go.
My creation.
My son!
You can do it!
I brought you into this world!
Wait, can I keep drawing?
Oh, it's so loud.
Yes, my son!
Claim 10 coin.
Speed level 1, 15 coins.
Okay, hold on.
Searching for him!
There's opponents!
Oh.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna draw what she draws.
Tamara?
I got this.
I'm the king.
Tamara!
She took the lead!
Oh my god.
Too many legs.
Wait.
Oh, too small.
Is this Uma Musume?
I failed already.
Tamara again?
She's obsessed with this game.
It's a car.
It's a car, you guys.
It's
a car.
Go, go, go.
Yeah, my son!
Go, go, go!
Go!
No!
Can you imagine if Uma Musume was like this?
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes!
Vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom!
Tamara, urara!
Wait, what should we draw next?
What should we draw next?
I'm gonna try and color in the whole thing.
Ar-Arnaldo?
Oh!
Wait.
Oh.
Wait!
No, they're too small!
He can't move!
Go, my son, go.
What did he draw?
Go up the stairs, come on.
Come on, my son!
A snake?
There we go.
Oh,
please!
Oh, we're not gonna make it!
I think they drew curly for us.
Who is this?
Ar-Arnaldo!
Who is this guy?
Make more cars.
Oops.
The game is...
Okay.
Wait, he drew something else this time.
It's actively sabotaging me.
I think it's AI too.
I think it's a bot as well.
I came and decided to buy...
Thank you, EB!
Uh-oh.
What if I draw a sad face?
Oh no!
I don't think we're gonna make it.
What do?
What should we draw?
Oh wait, I'm gonna draw...
I'm gonna draw...
Um...
A wisp?
The
game is sabotaging...
The game is sabotaging me.
It's like...
Wacky arm inflatable tube...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is actually working though.
Go!
Wait, the wisp is winning!
I'm fast, right?
You're a genius!
Good job, team!
Good job, everybody.
Okay, we'll get a wisp this time for sure.
Okay.
Who is our opponent?
Bettany.
Okay.
You're gonna be a wisp with glasses.
It's our car!
Wait, this is actually working.
Definitely not poo.
No!
It's not poo!
One of the boxes stops for a cup of tea.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, what a stride!
Oh!
This was a clear winner!
Not even clo- Almost!
20!
Wait!
This is a perfect score, you guys!
That was a perfect...
What should we draw now?
What should we draw?
A star?
That would be...
Oh yeah, that's actually kind of good.
Okay.
It looks a little wonky.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh no, we're stuck.
Okay, back to star.
Wait, what if I just draw legs?
Damn!
We swept the competition!
Skedaddling like a...
We...
Minto sweep!
Draw little boots, okay.
Who's our next opponent?
Shiro!
You would think Shiro's from Japan.
Okay, hold on.
Little booties.
I guess that works.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
We need some grip!
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
I can't believe their legs broke!
That was brutal!
I imagine the Mario like...
Every time it's...
It's flailing in the air.
We made it!
Let's try!
Hold on.
We've been doing L's, but let's do like a backwards L, you know?
Ralph!
Okay.
Like this.
This might be the real like grip, you know?
Oh, see, see, see?
I wonder what the purple wall...
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
You got this.
You got this long legs.
Let me in now.
And it would be nice.
Oh.
We lost.
Oh, seven!
We could try that.
Maybe this works.
Uh-oh.
Well, I'm gonna figure out...
I'm gonna figure out what the purple wall does.
Uh-oh.
Oh, seven.
Meet-to-kuso-gei streams are always the best because of how much they make you...
Nick Cage is great.
What was that movie?
Long Legs?
Shall we try a different game?
Draw Climber was good.
What else we got in here?
Puh-puh.
Puh-puh!
A tack hole?
Sandwich?
You guys wanna play Sandwich?
Let's play...
Let's try Sandwich.
Incredible!
Impressive!
It's like telling me...
This has gotta be still tutorial though, no?
Cause it's like...
God game!
Wonderful nerd emoji!
It shouldn't matter, like...
The order...
That ham is...
This is a thick sandwich.
Where's the meat?
That's what the pink stuff is!
It's ham!
No!
Whole can of Spam...
Oh, we're starting to get fancy tricky now, huh?
Lots of cheese...
A lot of cheese...
That's a lot of cheese...
Minto making me a sandwich?
I should bless them each time, no?
Oh, wait...
Can I...
Oh, it works?
Okay...
Oh, it works, okay...
Oishiku naare!
Moe, moe...
Killin!
Delicious!
Camera-san...
Camera-man...
What?
Okay...
You just gotta...
I think...
I guess you...
Do one move...
And it gets rid of the bee...
Why is there a bee in our...
Yeah, see?
Sandwich?
Not the bees!
More Nick Cage...
Ooh!
Tasty...
How do you not do this correctly...
Is my question...
Because...
As we just saw...
I was able to put...
I...
Like...
You see?
Be like...
Oh...
I...
I answered my own question...
Answered my own question...
There we...
That's how...
I wonder how complicated they get...
We'll go up to like...
Level 25...
There's a fly in my soup!
Oh...
I missed the part where that's my problem...
Deportation...
Yummy!
Oh...
Oh, but then they all open up...
Oh, I did it again...
My bad...
Come on...
There we go...
There's a bee in there...
Because sandwiches made you...
Made by you...
Or all the buzz!
Oh...
Interesting...
So like...
This...
Wait...
I feel like I could get addicted to this one...
I'm not gonna lie...
I feel like this one is just like...
I could get like...
You know...
Just...
All day long...
Sandwich making stream...
Wait...
What level?
Okay...
I think I've seen how complicated...
They can get by now...
Um...
Oh...
See?
It's kinda getting interesting...
These are the tallest sandwiches...
Known to man...
The hungriest person ever...
And why are there so many bees?
Why?
Why do we have so...
Such a bee problem?
Zoinks...
Like...
I need...
The biggest sandwich ever...
It's me...
Shaggy...
With the biggest sandwich...
It's just...
I like how they put...
Like...
Eggie on it too...
It's kinda good...
Nice...
Is that onion?
Oh wait...
It's a BLT!
Bee!
We added new ingredients...
Onion and bacon...
Nah...
Oh my god...
They're kinda cute...
The little bees...
Okay...
I think I'm good with this one...
We tried...
We made sandwiches...
I wanna sculpt people...
I'm very curious with sculpt...
I'm gonna make you guys...
Okay...
Let's sculpt...
Let's choose our clay...
You guys...
This is perfect!
Infinity...
Oh...
Pretty...
Okay...
Oh...
It's okay...
We're getting her...
Don't worry...
Yep...
Oh...
Ha...
I'm rounding it out...
Nice...
I'm sculpting you...
This is your likeness...
Uh...
Just got my first paycheck...
I wanted to celebrate...
By letting you have a slice of the pie...
Enjoy your sandwiches...
Bye...
Congrats...
Thank you...
Wait...
It kinda looks like handsome Squidward...
How do I...
Oh...
Beautiful...
What am I...
Oh...
Wait...
What do you want me to...
Huh?
Looks just like me...
Yeah...
I thought we were...
Painting the mask...
Maybe I am...
Careful...
I think I got...
The mustache already...
Oh...
I'm making this guy in the background...
I think...
No?
Wait...
I don't understand how this works...
I'm...
I'm confused...
Oh...
See...
Wait...
What's this?
I'll give him ears...
I'll give him some eyes...
I'll give him his heart...
I'll give him...
What is this?
What is that?
Beautiful!
Is this a tattoo?
Oh...
Wow...
Wait...
What is this?
Did you...
Graphic design is our best...
And pretty good at next level...
Yes...
It's the Hamburglar...
Do you guys...
Did you guys ever watch Hard Gay?
He was like a...
Comedian...
In...
In Japan...
And he would go...
Ha Doge...
Hoo!
Every time he would like...
Come out...
They would play...
Ricky Martin...
Okay...
I think we're good here...
It's you!
Incredible...
Oh...
Oh my god...
10 out of 10 game...
Yes...
Oh...
Wow...
Wait...
Iron Man...
No...
Wait...
Go back...
I saw...
Is that Homer Simpson?
Oh no...
There is Elsa...
Elsa feet!
Oh no...
No...
Wait...
Oh gosh...
I can't move this thing...
Is this good enough?
Oh, YouTube!
You had the sneaker in here, didn't you?
Green, red... Oh!
Come back, everybody!
Nimi, thank you so much for the redirect!
Hi, everybody!
I'm playing games on YouTube!
Did you know that YouTube had games?
I don't know how to get out of this.
Elsa...
Elsa, please!
Oh, okay, I went back.
I think...
Okay...
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Ruvik, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Ah, Shun, thank you so much for the five gifted!
My conditions were made...
Goodbye, bitch!
Oh,
it's really cursed!
Make the jonkler...
This one?
Yeah, we'll make the... Okay.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you guys so much for the gifted!
Thank you!
Scarlet, thank you!
Virgil, thank you!
Ravi, thank you!
Thank you guys so much!
Alrighty, let's make the jonkler...
In...
Sim...
Simly clay?
Right!
We'll give him...
We'll give him the jonkler face.
Alright.
Oh gosh!
I don't like this part.
Cool!
I don't like this part at all.
It's really scary.
I'm making the jonkler, everybody.
This is how you sculpt.
Truly.
Wait!
I can stop it whenever I want!
I can stop whenever I want!
Okay.
Let's give him some...
Wait.
Let's give him red here?
Oh wait.
Isn't it opposite?
Hold on.
It's gr...
It's red here.
And then green on his eyes, right?
My bad.
I messed it up.
Actually, we can make it any color we want.
Okay.
Here.
Green.
All green.
Wait, his nose?
Green.
What's...
How can I use his back?
Keep going!
I don't think we can.
Okay.
Beautiful!
Give him some ears.
Oh.
Wait.
We keep giving him ears.
Oh!
Give him some eyes.
Oh my gosh.
Blue...
Blue-eyed person staring at you.
What's this?
A brain?
Oh, hair?
Oh, I can give him...
Oh.
And then...
We finish it off with...
With my signature.
It isn't a Minto original.
Without...
Without him.
Make him...
Make it his eyebrows, actually.
Oh, yeah!
Just like the movie!
You wanna know how I got these scars?
Wait.
This should be scars, huh?
You wanna know how I got these scars?
Ugh.
Get...
Jonkled.
Yippee!
Give him brown context.
Wait, what's this?
What is...
Oh.
What am I doing?
What is this?
I'm filling the box with S.
Now that you mentioned him...
I'm getting flashbacks of Howard O'Gain...
Taking a random street guy's cigarette...
And putting it in his pants...
And then dancing.
Yeah, he did that.
S...
S for society!
Society!
Oh, yeah!
Okay, I think I'm done sculpting people.
That was...
Guess their answer!
Okay, let's try it.
Let's guess their answer.
If all of us guess, we'll truly be able to...
To know.
We will know.
Minto.
It looks like an iPhone.
Okay.
Look at me go.
Versus...
Penny?
Pear!
Oh, shoot.
Already given.
Oh!
Starfruit!
Hell yeah!
Yellow fruit!
Banana!
Oh yeah!
Uh...
Durian?
Wrong.
Pineapple!
Goku kinda sucks at this.
I'm not gonna lie.
Mango?
It's like more orange, no?
Lemon!
I'm not good at these types of games.
What is...
This is like...
The price is...
Not the price is right.
Family feud!
What?!
Mango is not yellow!
Mango is orange and green and red!
Boo!
Goku!
Oh, the inside of Mango!
Uh...
Damn!
I get 85 bucks?
Wait, who am I gonna face off against next?
Superhero!
Superman!
Batman!
Uh...
Iron Man!
Aquaman!
Spider-Man!
Goku!
Goku literally only...
Wait, I actually guessed every single one of them.
That's crazy.
I guessed literally every single one!
That was crazy!
What?!
Whoa!
Sorry, Goku.
Goku is not a superhero.
He's a Super Saiyan.
Name a sport.
Basketball!
Base...
Man.
Um...
Soccer...
Uh...
Football!
What else?
Uh...
Ball?
Wrong.
Basement.
I was still thinking of like Aquaman and...
Uh...
Golf!
Good job, team!
Good job.
I don't think...
I think this is rigged.
I can't be getting every single answer right.
You know?
I feel like this is rigged.
Pick a chest!
Oh!
Easy, meeny, meeny, miny, moe.
Catch a tiger by his toe.
If he hollers, let him go.
My mom said to pick the very best one.
And you are it.
Ten bucks!
The most we could guide is 500...
Oh, I have three keys!
Okay...
Twenty
dollars!
We made it.
Who are we gonna fight now?
Push the buzzer.
Me!
I pushed the buzzer!
Oh my god!
We're killing him!
I'm dancing on his grave!
GG!
I'm going to the semi-finale...
Finals, you guys!
Best chest, bottom right.
I didn't open that one.
These are not real people.
Wait, there's like a bajillion people here.
Wait, I can change clothes!
Never mind, I cannot change clothes.
What's this?
Daily challenge!
Can you guess the most popular answer?
Guess the answer?
Oh!
Name of...
Breakfast beverage.
Orange juice.
Do I go?
Okay, I clicked it.
I'm surprised coffee isn't there, right?
Oh my god!
It's Sco...
You guys, this is Squid Game.
McDonalds!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Everybody else, die!
Die!
Oh!
Would you bless me with a happy birthday?
Shout out!
Help me...
Get my wife into Metal Gear.
Now she's in love with the Legend of Oslo.
Of course...
Nighthater!
Wait...
Is it your birthday?
Or your wife's birthday?
Anyways...
Happy birthday!
Oh!
I lived?
Wait...
Answer faster.
Oops, I got distracted.
Yeah, I'll try again.
We got this easy!
I didn't even get burnt.
Name a sportswear brand.
N...
Nike!
Final answer!
Oh my gosh, I almost picked Crocs.
I almost picked Crocs, you guys!
I would've died!
Okay, okay!
Name something you never leave home without.
Phone.
My pet.
I'm kinda curious about aquapark.io.
The people are dying.
The children are crying.
Name somewhere you can swim.
I mean, you could swim in any of these.
Technically.
Do I have to split the prize money?
Holy 600 bucks!
Wow, okay.
Okay.
I'm going against Liliana.
Round one, go!
Can you...
Where can you find...
Oh, a pencil.
Pen.
Uh...
What did you get wrong?
Eraser.
Uh...
Pitbull!
Mr. World...
World...
High...
Light...
Marker.
Okay, that works.
Ruler!
Whoa!
Guys, I think...
These games are rigged.
I'm gonna try something really off the wall next time.
Something kinda crazy.
Baby games.
Name a friend of Mickey Mouse.
Mickey Mouse.
Mouse.
Uh...
Who are you getting wrong?
Pluto!
Uh...
Sora?
Goku.
Um...
Oh...
Uh...
Riku.
I'm gonna see if he gets any more.
Pete!
S...
Sora...
Sora was wrong!
It was...
Oh, Daisy...
Jack!
Guys, remember that song?
Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da...
Jack!
Who is Pete?
Pete is the...
Big...
He's like a cat.
He's the... He's like the... He's the... The big cat guy that... He's the bad guy... Yeah, somehow he's a... Somehow he's a cat.
He's the big cat.
The big bully.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What can you do on... You got games?
Um... Tinder.
Wrong.
Uh... What else can you do on a phone?
Calculator.
Wow, that worked.
YouTube.
Videos.
Um... Internet.
Wrong.
Text.
Call.
Easy.
I should have said TikTok.
Oh, they said photos.
I don't know why I completely forgot what you can do on a phone all of a sudden.
Dang, I got a lot of money for that.
Okay, bottom right.
Ten bucks.
It would take things... A burglar would not want to see...
Wait, for... Wait, what?
Top left.
Okay, this is the 500.
Wait, best reward is a puzzle piece.
Oh my gosh, I got the puzzle piece!
Nice!
We can go to the beach!
Alright, time to die.
Oh my god!
I killed Pitbull!
Oh, they're so sad.
Wait, can I get new clothes?
Random skin, 200.
Random skin, 400.
Old man.
Random skin, 600.
Is that Kill Bill?
Dan...
Oh!
Oh, uh...
Game of Thrones!
I can't say her name.
Oh, TikTok.
Um...
Twitter.
Uh...
Uh, Instagram.
I'm only thinking of the things that I use.
YouTube.
I never think of that as like a...
As a social media platform, you know?
MySpace.
Let's see.
22?
Who are these boomers?
Oh, Facebook.
Oh my gosh.
It's like the quintessential.
I got literally every single one of them.
Girl, what are you doing?
Okay, I think I'm done with this game, though.
What else should we do?
Bazooka Boy.
Stealthmaster.
Or Cat Escape.
Wait, I feel like we have to do Stealthmaster, no?
Who uses Facebook anymore?
I don't know.
Cat Escape.
Kind of want to do something, like, exciting, you know?
Hmm.
Flappy Dunk.
Twisted Tangle.
Merge Master.
Fruit Ninja's right there.
Wait, where?
I don't see it.
I could do Running Pet.
What do you mean?
Harvest.
Harvest.io?
Harvestio?
I passed it?
Where?
Huh?
Ah,
I see it.
Fruit Ninja.
Wait, the original Fruit Ninja.
Is it actually?
Oh.
I did it.
Ah!
Oh, I've never played Fruit Ninja before.
Natsukashii!
Tashka ni.
Oh.
Oops, you've sliced the bomb, but congrats, you get three bomb deflects.
Nice.
I get three of them.
Whoa, combo!
Bumble Cup!
Whoa, this actually runs really smoothly, too.
This is impressive.
Oh, oopsie.
Making a fruit salad.
This is making me hungry a little bit.
It's making me a little hungry.
Wait, now you guys know you can play Fruit Ninja on YouTube if you ever knew.
My mate is also a ninja.
Ow!
Sorry.
What is this?
I'm actually Raiden!
Slice.
Oh, that was close.
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Just like Raiden.
Whoa, that was so close.
Oh no, wait.
I did accidentally touch it, I think.
Oops.
Nice.
Baby Sensory Video Revenge.
Oh, I missed one.
No!
I missed a fruit.
Oh, I'm getting fired.
I'm getting fired.
Why is the best 2-2-2, but my score is 2-2-7?
It's time for...
Woo!
Minto the Ladder Rip.
Doctor.
Nice.
I think I'm the best to ever do it.
Uh-oh, I think I lost another fruit.
Oh!
That was close.
I thought I got that banana.
Oh, I think I died!
No!
Is this dancing fruit for Ghost Forever 19 and people over 30?
What does that mean?
I wonder if these games, like, save your progress.
You know what I mean?
Or if...
Oh, wow!
Way!
This is so nice!
And if you guys ever want to play, you don't have to worry about ads.
Now you know.
This reminds me of the good old days after...
I wonder how many old Flash games are still around.
Maybe Crazy Monkey Armor games.
I don't...
I mean, I don't know that.
It's the whole game?
I think so!
We should try Fashion Battle.
Okay, let's try it.
Doctor.
Turn off my Coco Melon.
Ooh, girl!
I'm tapping to play.
Oh, oh, oh.
How do we have this?
What do you mean, nightclub?
How do we have stuff like this and then also, like, official license Fruit Ninja?
Glowing.
Wait, I want to choose my own hair!
Hmm.
Ooh, this is what they wear to the club.
Ooh.
The glasses?
This is...
Pretty.
Ooh.
Wait, the red would match better, though.
What the hell is this?
Oh.
Ooh.
Hmm.
Oh, I'm 10 out of 10, baby.
Oh, my God.
Get out of here, Emily.
It's my turn to shine.
I like how we just kill people in these games when...
They lose.
So much brutal murder today.
Likes or win prize.
Oh, so we can either get likes.
Okay.
Let's get likes.
We want the world to love us.
Oh.
Oh, I get it.
Okay, never mind.
I'm leveling up.
I thought that was, like, what battle you do.
Okay, just kidding.
All right.
Hannah.
Sport.
This is definitely a Roblox game.
This one.
Apply.
Oh, sexy.
I thought she said fancy.
What is this?
Oh.
So chic.
Mint is 11 out of 10.
Thanks.
Oh, damn.
Oh, this is cute.
Oh, my God.
Stunning.
Yes, queen.
Stylish.
Roblox game.
Yeah.
Okay, I think I'm done with this one.
Killer.
She even got moves.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's try something else.
Race Master 3D.
What is family life?
What is this?
I'm a lady.
We're playing YouTube games.
Did you guys know that YouTube has games?
It's the Baker family.
Wait, what's happening?
I'm making money per second.
Oh.
Taya and Tobias met at a basketball game.
Make fun of this game.
It's Tobias' favorite star.
Wait.
What do you mean love?
What's bit life?
Take off.
Thanks for the good time.
Um.
Play basketball together.
Taya and Tobias have fallen in love.
What?
You played basketball once?
Oh my gosh, you guys.
New meta.
If you ever want to get married.
Oh.
You know how it's like...
Okay.
Remember how there's like the...
I want to drink your miso soup every...
Every day or whatever.
Now it's like...
Instead of Netflix and chill.
Do you want to like...
Play basketball together?
Valentine, thank you so much for the game.
Thank you.
Um.
Have a free live stream.
Oh my gosh.
Content, baby.
Why are you sad?
You just got married.
Why are you so sad?
Oh.
Have a baby.
Taya is...
It happened so fast.
Oh.
We have like so much money.
Best doctor in town.
Unlock the life point event.
A baby.
Minus $74.
$74 per second.
What?
Is he eating the cash?
Oh my god.
Each newborn baby produces one life point.
That is retained even if the game fails.
You can use life points to redeem these amazing event rewards.
They have about $10k on the road.
That's...
That's enough money that you need to turn it in.
If you keep that money, you will go to jail.
Yeah, that's mafia money.
That is dirty money.
Can we play YouTube games and get married?
No, we're playing YouTube games and basketball.
Okay, let's do $10k on the road.
We're going to jail, baby.
Oh, okay.
The music is so Sims, right?
Warren's dad...
To buy...
Oh, okay.
Warren is the baby.
Want to give him a more unique and meaningful name.
Woody.
Wait.
Wally or...
Hey there, Woody.
I've got a snake in my boot.
Okay, we just renamed our baby.
More, more, more.
Have another baby!
Taya and Tobias feel...
Having another child would make their family even more complete.
How...
What's the timeline here?
Has it been like a week?
Keep pumping them out.
Yeah.
Have a baby.
What is search it online?
After the surgery, Taya feels sad and notices she's not as healthy.
Oh, no!
P.N.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
Where's our second baby?
Taya is angry because her boss has assigned her unreasonable tasks.
Requestionate...
What does this do?
Oh, okay.
Woody.
Like being named that, do you think?
The date is up on the top?
This?
This is no date?
This is our cash.
Money.
Um...
Avchi just had a baby.
Request an extension.
P.N.
The leader not only disagrees, but also mocks Taya?
Why is the baby more expensive?
Oh, my God.
The boss thought Taya wasn't working hard and scolded Taya in front of everyone.
Show your evidence.
The boss was very angry.
Oh, no!
Uh-oh.
Why are...
We're in the red.
Is this a roguelike?
I think so.
Oh, my gosh.
Refresh.
We'll find a different job.
Receptionist.
Refresh.
Chef, but more money.
Our last job was 201 per second.
Refresh.
Driver.
We're getting there almost.
Event planner.
Refresh.
No!
Event planner.
Refresh.
We can get...
Oh, oh.
It's going down.
190.
Final answer.
That might be...
That might be our closest.
Gosh.
What's...
This job market is the easiest ever.
Taya has a new job!
Woohoo!
This game has...
Sort of language I see in scammy bills.
Taya has been arguing with parents over trivial matters.
Time to say goodbye!
Taya continues to experience a worsening relationship with parents.
Sad.
What about this guy?
He's happy.
He's way happier than her.
Yeah, Taya's getting all the drama.
Oh.
He seems to be suffering from...
From...
Yellow fever.
Are we...
I'm going to wish for a miracle.
Don't die.
Uh-oh.
Feels the condition is worse.
Dysentery.
In Mongolia, they have some pretty crazy drinks.
Ai...
Ai rag...
Which is fermented mare's milk.
And sutei sai...
Which is salty tea.
Probably choose the tea.
Tobias is a freak.
It's okay.
We're still fine.
Now walk it off.
Yeah, this is Oregon Trail.
Holy cow.
Taya has been replaced by someone else in her position.
Leading to an awkward situation.
Look for opportunities for promotion.
Develop own skills.
Search for new jobs.
Let's develop our own skills.
Oh.
Taya paid for training to get better skills.
We have so much money.
We can...
We can waste $2,000.
The year is 2019.
The black plague has decreased.
My wife's health.
Points by 20.
I like how we're young, Taya.
Yeah.
We're baby, Taya.
We were just bored.
And suddenly we got married after basketball.
Healthy eating habits.
Become a gym rat.
Drink lots of water.
Do nothing.
Hit the gym.
Gym rat arc.
Teya gradually shapes her ideal physique through fitness exercises.
Ooh.
Yeah, baby.
Wait.
What happened to the other baby?
The plague.
I forgot the baby at the hospital.
Clearly.
Teya is anxious about the progress of her project.
Work overtime.
Request an extension.
Well, that last time got us in trouble.
So work overtime, baby.
Uh-oh.
She's physically and mentally affected.
I don't think I know how to.
I'm dead.
So I don't think I know how to live.
Oh my god.
The baby, Woody, is having issues too.
Woody was scratched by a stray cat while playing in the park.
Cry on the spot.
Catch the stray cat.
Why is it like a smirking cat emoji?
Wait.
New pet.
Woody was played around by the wild cat.
Uh-oh.
Handsome Woody might die, everybody.
Our baby is so handsome.
What the?
That is not an elementary student.
That is a grown-ass man.
What?
Handsome Woody.
Woody has reached the age to attend elementary school.
Go to elite private school.
He's still a deficit in our life.
Tobias is angry because his boss has assigned him unreasonable tasks.
Why does this keep happening?
Weak Tobias?
That's his name?
I thought you guys were just calling him weak earlier because of the...
Because of the yellow fever.
Punish Tobias.
He seems pretty like...
Soft boy.
I think he could PN his way out of this.
No!
Tobias was fired!
Start a business.
Tobias wants to open a department store in this economy.
What do you mean?
Invest...
30k?
We don't have that.
It's just a 1% chance.
Tobias, you're too weak!
We're going into debt, everybody.
Tobias opens a department store, but no customers should have.
Oh.
Current balance is...
Minus 9,447k.
And you will go broke soon.
Um...
We will borrow $100,000.
Thank you.
How long do you need to repay the loan?
10 years.
Yay!
Well, some people are...
Are...
Not contributing anything!
Free 100k.
Let's go, baby!
Gaming is everything of my life.
Wait.
Teo finds everyday life monotonous and wants to make a change.
Yeah, gaming.
Teo is greatly affected physically.
What's wrong with Gaby?
Oh my god!
You guys, am I unhappy?
Tobias has found a new job.
Wait.
Refresh.
80...
Dog walker?
Tobias, you're too weak.
Oh my god.
We should have never...
We should divorce this man.
Electrician for only $84 per second is insane.
Gaming wrecked the whole family.
Cleaner for $95.
Okay, accept.
Yeah, Tobias!
Making that money back, baby.
Let's go.
Yeah, per second.
Woody has been overwhelmed with a lot of homework lately and feels exhausted.
Ask the teacher.
Fill in random answers.
Spend more time.
Discuss with classmates.
Let's ask the teacher.
Woody receives better guidance and correction on his homework.
Completing it faster and reducing the burden.
Oh!
We made a good choice, you guys.
Chat GPT.
Oh!
Woody doesn't exercise regularly.
Has a weak immune system.
From his father!
And frequently falls ill.
Yeah, I wonder why.
I wonder who's making our child sick.
Yellow fever incoming!
Dysentery for all!
Let's stick to an exercise routine.
Oh!
Let's go charming, Woody.
Wait, you're not handsome anymore?
Is it because you grew up?
You were a handsome baby, you know?
Woody failed the last exam in fine arts.
Read the course is spelled wrong.
What should we do?
Weak bloodline confirmed.
Tobias was our biggest mistake.
How do you fail art?
What do you mean study with a friend?
Give up?
Give up.
Woody has made no progress in his studies.
Aw, Woody.
Weak like your father.
Pathetic.
Pathetic, Woody.
That should be your new name.
Oh my gosh, Woody is going through it.
Woody's grades and career and technical education have declined.
Give up!
We'll redo.
Woody has improved his grades!
He did it.
I'm mean tonight.
I'm just, uh...
I just wanted to cause a little chaos.
Woody brought his girlfriend...
How old are you, Woody?
I thought you were in elementary school.
He brought a girlfriend home.
Warn them they are too young for that.
Tell Woody's girlfriend to get lost.
Hey, didn't you have two babies?
I don't know.
Where the other baby...
I think we...
I think the other baby...
We left at the hospital.
Hey Woody, that's our girlfriend.
Ignore them.
Tell Woody's girlfriend to get lost.
Oh, that's it.
That's all that happened.
Do you think if she...
If we welcomed her, she would be...
She would be...
In our family tree.
Taya believes her salary is unfair.
Wait, what's a 70% chance of salary raise?
Let's go.
Taya seems to be suffering from...
Hypoglycemia.
Wish for a miracle.
Oh.
Taya feels the condition is worse.
I don't think we have very good luck with this family.
Woody considers whether to do homework.
Conscientiously complete homework.
Refuse to do homework.
I like these emojis.
Do your homework, Woody.
Come on, Woody.
Gosh.
Oh.
Woody has reached the age to attend middle...
See?
He was an elementary school student getting a girlfriend.
What?
Oh.
This is the date?
So it's...
Is it January 3rd?
It's 2030?
Wait.
Is that the date?
Um.
Damn.
Okay.
You're going to a public middle school.
Charming, Woody.
Oh.
I see.
Yeah.
So it's April 17th, 2030.
I thought that was just the timer.
Man's got riz.
Teya is overwhelmed by work pressure and feels exhausted every day.
Find ways to relax.
Come on.
We were weak, Teya.
Now we're young, Teya.
It worked.
But we're still...
Oh.
Wait.
It's happy Tobias now.
Okay.
Woody found that a classmate was cheating on it.
No snitching.
Turn a blind eye.
Woody focused on his own studies.
Good Woody.
Woody is expensive, you guys.
I'm just going to say that right out.
Woody is pretty pricey.
Woody stays up late and sleeps very late.
Continue staying up late.
Yeah, his health worsens.
Mama didn't raise no snitch.
Yeah.
Tobias.
Tobias, become a gym rat just like your wife.
Happy Tobias.
The gym rat arc.
What if we could sell Woody to make a profit?
I think that would be the good option.
He's not a good investment.
This is a capitalistic society.
Woody always gets poor education in business.
Sell him.
Redo the course.
Oh, he has improved.
Good job.
Wait, is he old now?
No, he's charming, Woody.
Tobias feels frustrated because his colleagues frequently disrupt his work.
Yells at him.
Communicate with colleagues.
Report the situation to superiors.
I can stand that.
Yells at him.
Tobias, it's time for you to become angry, Tobias.
Yell.
The colleague realizes his mistake, apologizes, and promises not to do it again.
Oh my god, wait, it worked?
That worked?
How?
Woody has reached high school already?
Woody, you're too expensive.
Public high school for you.
Public high...
When are you going to bring home a girlfriend, though, Woody?
Come on.
Social studies grades have declined.
Redo.
Good job.
I think redoing it works every time.
Woody is not good at arts or business or social studies or anything.
Oh, Woody.
Woody dislikes doing chores and finds them boring.
Do chores or get beaten.
Oh my god!
We're building character here.
Charming Woody?
No.
Punished Woody.
Woody is gradually accepting the arrangement of household chores.
It worked!
What the happiness went up to?
Wait.
Teya's picture changed.
Woody failed his last exam inside.
This guy can't do anything!
Redo.
He can't do...
Look!
Oh, we're middle-aged Teya.
And happy Tobias.
Why is she middle-aged and he's happy?
Okay.
Is anything else gonna happen?
Tobias wants to buy a lottery ticket.
Ticket costs $9.
Jackpot...
Buy 10.
Tobias did not win.
This is like a buy 90 bucks.
How long have we had this...
this loan for?
Woody's classmates were all using luxury cosmetics.
Continue using cheap makeup.
Steal a classmate's makeup.
Steal.
Oh!
It worked!
We didn't get in trouble at all.
There was no punishment.
Woody!
Poor grades and health!
Oh my gosh!
Do you study anything?
What are you...
What are you doing?
$4,000 for makeup.
That's insane.
Woody is anxious about his upcoming school competition.
Give up.
Practice more.
Do nothing.
Practice.
Good job, Woody.
He has no redeeming qualities.
Oh!
Tobias seems to be suffering from eczema.
Me too, Tobias.
Oh my god, no, Tobias.
Don't die from eczema, please.
Wish for a miracle.
It worsens.
What?
How is this condition?
It's eczema.
The lethal eczema.
Our wife is going to think we're ugly.
No.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Woody has a lot of charm.
And also costs a lot of freaky...
Wait.
Woody costs almost as much money as we make.
Welcome Woody's classmates warmly.
Okay.
Wait.
We're not making any money, you guys.
Uh-oh.
That died from the yellow fever eggs.
What?
Um.
You're not going to university.
You are working, baby.
No.
Why are you still...
A deficit?
Oh my god.
Look at...
We're losing money.
A streamer!
Woody found a new job as a streamer.
He's making...
More than our mom.
Wait.
Middle-aged Taya wants to go on a trip.
We don't have...
Fly to the moon?
Wait.
What do you mean there's a 50% chance...
Of dying?
Found
the footprint of Armstrong on the moon.
Oh.
We are in excessive debt.
Your family survived until 2030...
They died!
We died from debt, everybody.
We died.
That was so sad.
Died of debt.
Our family survived until 2037.
You know what?
It's longer than I expected.
I'm not going to lie.
Probably shouldn't have gone to the moon.
But it was worth it.
She saw Armstrong's footprint on the moon.
What is this alien shooter?
Whoa.
What other games we got in here?
Cat...
Wait.
Magic Cat Academy.
Adorable Home.
Merge Hero.
Bro.
These are so much like the ads.
Do you guys want to play Foot Chinko or Homo Evolution?
Do you want to play Foot Chinko or Homo Evolution?
Which one?
No skills in arts.
Business science.
Has health issues.
No university prospects.
Perfect streamer material.
Actually, though...
Time to evolve.
This one has...
6.5 million plays.
I wonder which one has the most plays on it.
Oh, wait.
These are for me.
Wait.
Uh...
What is skincare time?
This looks...
This looks like some, like, Elsa...
Pimple poppin'.
You know...
Booger...
Booger wiping.
Kind of nastiness, you know?
Phantom is you.
Yeah.
Are you a bot?
At least these have no ads.
I know, right?
Angry Birds?
Do we Angry Birds time?
I feel like...
We could always play Angry Birds whenever...
Let's see...
I keep seeing...
I keep wanting to play this because it has a dinosaur.
But then I see it's just a merge game.
Then Crossy Road.
I've seen that one before.
What's this?
Oh, Scavenger Hunt.
Woody may have died on the moon.
But it was worth it for the content.
I should go to the moon then.
50% chance, baby!
I might...
Live!
Well, I'm already dead.
State.io online PvP.
I feel like that might...
Not be good.
If it's like...
Hi, you're in this state.
Pirate Pop.
Foot Chinko.
Oh, that's the Flappy Foot Chinko.
Lake Jump.
Minesweep.
Wait, Classic Minesweeper?
Sushi Roll.
Trivia Crack.
Ringy Dingy.
Wait, is this like a...
What's it called?
Game?
Oh, Rhythm Game?
Boss, what if the moon is sentient?
What?
Swipe.
Is this a tutorial?
The Pokeball.
Oh.
Wait, am I doing it right?
I don't like the sound it makes.
Oh.
Let me turn it down.
I thought it was going to be a...
Rhythm Game.
I can't tell what the size of these things are.
Exaling.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Oh!
Oh, I made it!
oops.
Okay, I think I understand now.
Oh, I get it.
Oh, it even shows me where I can place it.
It's not entirely stupid.
Wait, shouldn't this be a cross?
Come on.
Color stack.
Okay, I'm done with this one.
I didn't like it.
I didn't like that one.
I want to build a queen, baby.
Let's build a queen.
Play magic cat.
Yeah, I was not impressed.
That one.
Oh.
Oh, we... I did test this one before.
Oops.
I kind of... just to see if these games were actually playable.
Use this.
Oh, okay.
Thank you, game.
So you're supposed to build the person that is on the right.
Um... Like, the top right.
I made her head really big, though.
Oh, I... Yeah, I think we still got this.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
We still got the man.
Okay.
Now it's getting interesting.
Wow.
Oh.
Oh, theme is my...
Style.
Um... Let's go with a redhead.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Nope.
Those are not my style.
Oh.
Let's go with some pink shoes.
These shoes.
Money.
Pink.
Oh, yeah.
This is a game.
What is that?
Oh.
I just put that on.
Uh, put on eye shadow.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Did I do it?
The quality of these games really just...
Stunns you, huh?
Oh.
Theme is summer.
Oh, my God.
She's booking it.
This one.
Can I run?
Can I please run?
Oh.
This one.
Oh, my gosh.
The hat.
Wait.
She stole my outfit.
Why do we have the same outfit on?
Uh, eye shadow.
Okay.
Uh.
Oh.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
What do we do?
We look the same.
I lost.
Wait.
Is that the one we were supposed to do?
Why is she up there?
She's like up there in heaven.
Okay.
I think I'm good with build a coin.
I think I'm good.
She copied me.
I like blue for summer.
Yellow for summer for sure.
No.
Blue is so much better.
I kind of want to play family life again.
I'm not going to lie.
That was kind of awesome.
Cat escape.
Let's do...
I'm trying to find the ones that I have like the most plays.
Like this one, Racemaster, has 31 million plays.
Now it's 32 million.
Hold to ride.
Okay.
How do I speed up?
Can I drift?
Okay.
How do I get faster?
Oh my god.
There's bouncy balls.
What the hell?
How do I get faster?
Oh my god.
There's sheep.
Oh yeah, baby.
I'm getting faster.
I'm going.
Ah!
I crashed and I died.
Okay.
Is this Rocket League?
Maybe.
Bouncy balls.
Me, me, me, me, me.
I finished the race.
Cute mouse pointer.
Thank you.
How does this have so many...
So many plays.
Oh my god.
Oh, they're losing control.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
Bouncy balls.
Wait, you guys.
We might make it the first.
We're in first.
Oh my god.
The bouncy ball.
This is what kids play on their computer these days.
Clearly.
Let's invest in...
Yeah.
Yeah, baby.
Look at that.
Oh, whoops.
Look at that little beetle.
I
maybe deserve that.
I maybe deserve that.
I can drive really well, you guys.
This is not a testament, okay?
Oh, I wasn't paying attention.
Sorry.
I was looking at that really long name.
I'll still make money.
It doesn't matter what place I am.
Oh gosh, I was so late.
They were waiting for me.
Yikes.
Top speed.
Oh, I maybe should have done more acceleration.
Whatever.
My Oshii should not be behind the wheel.
No, it's good.
It's good.
Accelerate.
Yeah.
Oh.
Accelerate.
We can catch up.
It's still early.
It's anyone's game.
Maybe.
See, see, see.
I'm already almost up.
Caught to them.
Whoa.
We're doing twists and turns.
I'm almost caught up.
I'm caught up.
Oh, they fall.
Oh, they're stupid.
I'm already in second place.
I'm so good at this game.
I'm good at this game.
Boss fight.
Oh, we have to collect things to get the boss fight.
Let's do more acceleration.
We don't need handling.
Handling is all me, baby.
I handle it.
What the hell?
Space invader.
Whoa, we're in Tetris world.
What in the vapor wave is this?
Oh, hey.
Oh, my gosh.
They're trying to kill me.
Oh, my God.
There's a doggy dog world out there.
I'm going to do racing games in real life.
I'm going to become a street racer and do exactly like this.
See you, sucker.
I'm too good.
We unlocked the RGV.
Let's go, RGV.
What is this?
I think this is probably, if it's a mobile game, you can adjust.
Oh, yeah.
That guy's T-posing on me.
They're clapping.
More acceleration.
Are any of these games legit?
I don't know.
You tell me.
Everybody's going crazy.
The L.
This one's kind of addicted.
I'm not going to lie.
This one's kind of fun.
Hey!
I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to murder you off the road.
I'm already caught up.
Because I'm so good at this game.
This
one.
We did, in fact, need handling.
No!
We...
No, we didn't.
Okay, I got to know what fork and sausage is.
You are amazing.
Thanks, Link.
Thank you.
My name is Mitt Phantom, and welcome to Jackass.
Bow, bow, bow.
Oh, yeah.
Oh!
Out of curiosity, are you friends with a headless motorcycle rider with a yellow helmet?
More than friends.
Oh, it already fell.
So I didn't even do anything.
Oh, they suck.
It's kind of hard.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
I am stuck in here.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, I don't understand the physics at all, I think.
I don't understand the physics at all, I think.
You can spam click.
Oh, I did it.
I'm surprised they don't give you, like, a certain number of tries, you know?
Surprise box.
Hot dog.
Pudding.
Oh, whoa.
The pudding does way more than I expected.
Oh, oh, oh.
That sounds kind of fun.
Boing.
Bozingo.
Oh, we got a key here.
Oops.
How did you miss?
Toaster.
Not much of a surprise if we see it on the bottom.
That was clean.
That was fun.
What else should we do, guys?
What else should we do?
I kind of want to go back to the family one.
Can you sing happy birthday for me?
I'm not doing birthday songs right now, but happy birthday, Link.
Happy, happy birthday.
Cut the rope.
I see twisted tangle.
Was there a cut the rope?
Oh my gosh, this one's also intelligence challenge.
This one's also like those ads.
Prison life?
We did that one already earlier.
Yeah, yeah.
Merge cakes.
Down, cut the rope.
Cut the rope.
Oh wait.
Let's try Magic Cat Academy.
Are those ghosts?
Oh wait, there's a cut scene?
Ha ha ha.
Me!
Wait, this is so fancy.
Oh, uh, what did it say?
Uh oh.
Defeated ghosts by drawing its symbol anywhere.
Ah!
Oh, that's kind of fun.
Ha!
Level one.
Oh!
Draw!
Oh, I see.
Whoa!
Whoa.
What
the hell is this math?
Oh my god.
Oh.
These are getting crazy.
No!
We lost a house.
These are crazy.
Is it...
It's my own kind.
Yeah, but this cat...
Cat is important.
Draw!
Friend!
Wait.
What if we draw a mint symbol?
What's that?
Oh gosh.
What is this one?
If I draw...
Oh, I was gonna say.
If I draw a heart, will it...
Will it work?
Ha!
I guess this is way easier with your finger, huh?
You know?
I imagine.
Because I feel...
Tricky...
With my...
Ah!
My god is ass.
I feel tricky with my mouse.
Cart was a bonus after the boss.
Oh!
Tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick-tick.
It was hard on mobile too?
Really?
Level 3!
Level 3.
Oh my gosh.
They get really...
Wait, I'm gonna write a message to you guys.
Wait, what'd that do?
Oh, that's so cute!
Shut up, really?
It actually works!
Oh my gosh!
That's so cute!
Nice.
Oh no, the boss.
The boss, the boss, the boss, the boss.
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Stay away, foul beast!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
He's too fast!
He's fast.
Dang, I carved your symbol on my wall.
What do you mean?
Sweet Gim.
Alright, this is pretty fun, actually.
This one is like Fruit Ninja, but not.
Oh my gosh.
Holy moly.
Oh my god, that was close.
Oh no, we're gonna die!
This one's actually kinda legit.
It's hard though, oh my gosh.
What?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Mr.Cow...Cowboy.
Just one more.
Just one more and we're good.
Oh!
Final boss.
Level five.
Ready, set, draw!
Oh, that was so close.
I'm a pro.
Oh my god.
No!
I'm not a pro.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
We're good.
That one was tough.
That one was tricky.
You guys can do it.
Beat the ghost for me.
I actually didn't really want to beat the ghost though.
What is Pooh?
Po?
2025?
This is recent?
Welcome to Pooh.
Pooh is your pet alien who loves to eat and play.
Pooh is dirty.
Go to the bathroom and clean it with soap and water.
Try it now.
Use the soap bar to clean him.
Grab the soap and begin to scrub.
Oh.
Oh, he's...
I'm grabbing it.
I'm trying.
Wait.
I'm trying to grab it.
I'm grab...
Oh, here?
Nicely done.
Now, grab the shower.
I think I already hate this.
This is not...
This is an ugly...
Tamagotchi.
Let's dry him.
I refuse to say his name even.
And brush his teeth.
Ooh.
Well done.
Pooh is healthy again.
Pooh seems to be hungry.
Okay.
I don't want to play this anymore.
He's 20% close to becoming an adult.
Okay.
Pick up an apple and drag it.
Make him less hungry.
Try his different treats.
Broccoli.
Wait.
Why does that make him crazy?
Dress him in some...
He's 40% close to becoming an adult.
Yeah.
I kind of want to see him as an adult.
This one's...
Oh, let's make him very...
Oh.
Never mind.
We'll make him pink.
That looks great.
Add more clothing.
Ooh.
I can't...
Ooga.
Why is Ooga locked?
Bieber?
Let's do Zufi.
And the hat.
I can't do pirate?
That's not an ascot.
Oh my gosh.
Let's do a...
Gnome.
Animal.
Oh, wow.
Look at that.
B.
Great outfit.
Let's play some games.
Six...
Pooh is 60% close to becoming an adult.
This seems so intimidating.
We're playing games.
Skyhop.
Left and right arrow key.
Oh my...
Try a different game.
Wait.
How do I replay?
Skyhop.
Okay.
Oh.
One more time.
I got this.
I understand it now.
The music is so happy.
Watch me get copyright struck for this.
I'm a pro!
I'm insane!
Oh my god.
I can't...
I can't lose.
To the moon!
Wait.
There's a time limit?
I'm afraid of it.
Not...
It takes a second to register my clicks.
So I can't go much faster than when I'm going.
Oh my god!
We're gonna die poo!
This is it.
Wow.
How do I get back home?
I'm done playing game.
This is like a Spongebob...
Squarepants...
How do I get back home?
I'm gonna play these now.
I'm single-handedly saving YouTube's...
Playable games.
I need to do two more games?
Is that what it said?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Let's do Hill Drive.
Okay.
Why...
Where we get this hamster from!
We're driving on a watermelon!
Flash died for this!
Oh!
And so did we!
Oh my god!
The hamsters!
That was so much fun!
How about we go outside and play?
Pooh is 80% close to becoming an adult.
I can finally go home... and we can go outside.
This is outside.
Out here, you can water your plants and play with your pet.
Why not try one?
I'm playing with my pet.
Oh, I'm playing with my pet.
That's it!
Pooh is grown up!
Well done, you've hit level one.
Leveling up Pooh unlocks new items.
Oh, too much... Mucho texto.
Okay.
Wow!
Ooh, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Oh, okay.
We do this.
Oh...
This is... This is a game.
You're my child!
I want to play aquapark.io.
I've been seeing it on the side every time.
Why did he wolf whistle at me?
Why did he do that to me?
That was definitely a game.
Oh, what is this?
Wait, what actually... No, what actually...
Play.
Oh, we're choosing a cup?
The beach cup?
Oh my god!
These are definitely real people!
I'm killing everyone again.
Oh, and myself!
Oh, wait!
I'm the best ever to do it?
Wait, wait!
We can catch up!
You guys, we can catch
up!
Was that not a pool?
What did I...
Goodbye, DuckDuck!
Goodbye, everybody else!
Goodbye...
Goodbye, Jumbo!
I'm really killing these people!
Goodbye, ugly...
I don't know why I called you ugly.
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have done that.
I shouldn't have done that!
Wait, I can...
I can do this.
Wait, how am I only in second place?
Who is in first?
Oh my god.
Wait...
5,000!
This says that it had like millions of views.
How am I only...
I must be that good of a gamer.
Oh no, it's fall, guys.
You guys see that?
It said people out of qualif- Oh.
Guys, I don't think we made it.
Guys...
We didn't make it.
What else we got in here?
It really is just a mixed bag of things.
It just...
You have Mechagallion.
Robot what?
Robot fighting.
Try Solar Smash.
I did that one earlier.
Oh.
Yeah!
I beat the game!
Wait, what is this?
Brain out.
Okay.
I'm ready to brain out.
I'm ready.
Welcome back.
This is my first time here.
Find the biggest one.
What?
Congratulations!
You found it!
How many ducks?
Two, four, six, eight, ten.
No, nine.
That's a chicken.
Congratulations, sweetie!
Sweetie!
Who is the tallest one?
The sun!
Can you find the different one?
This music is gonna make me crash out.
Is it this one?
The impossible quiz or whatever?
Which claw is similar to the cat's outstretched claw?
This one?
No!
This one.
The cat's paw.
Oh.
I love meow!
Find the largest fire.
What's the...
What's the catch here?
Oh.
You're supposed to make it bigger.
What's the number...
Parked on...
Wait.
What's the number under the parked car?
Nine.
You
are a genius.
I like the...
I like the, uh...
The sayings.
I'm a genius.
You are awesome!
Find the chick.
What am I supposed to do with these?
There are three chicks on a...
There are three...
There are three chicks in a trench coat.
Is it the word?
No?
I actually don't get this one.
Are they Matryoshka-dolling?
Should play Angry Birds?
No!
I don't think I'll play the Angry Birds one because...
Shake them?
More obscure, you know.
Count the number of hairs.
Three.
I just tore all his hair out.
I made him...
Haha!
Not bad!
Bad for him, maybe.
Help baby duckling drink water.
There you go.
It reminds me of the story of the crows drinking water.
Yeah, you put the rock in there, right?
Can you solve this question?
What am I even supposed to click?
It's two, but like, what do I...
How do I make it two?
Ah...
I was like, where do I grab it from?
You are getting better and better...
This is my...
This is like the motivation I need.
Find something you can eat.
Is this ham?
Wow, that's the way.
I don't know what I did.
Cute and clever.
The little elephant is so lonely.
Shake it.
It'll make a chick.
I'll get this one.
Check behind the ear.
Can't click anywhere.
Get rid of the word lonely.
It's just a little elephant.
What does it do?
Hold and drag.
Hold and drag?
Where?
See
it?
Not longly anymore.
It's
not longly anymore.
No smoking.
What?
It's not this one.
Is it this one?
What?
It should be this one, no?
No, it's smoking.
I'm so lonely.
You can't move the smoke.
Did I say click on it there?
What if I say smoking?
Grab the two...
You can't.
You can't even grab him.
You can only move these.
You can't remove the no.
Hmm.
Put the X over the smoke.
No.
Cover the words.
Spam click.
It kind of looks like smoke though, doesn't it?
What
is the X that appears after?
Wipe it with the mouse.
Wait.
Oh my God.
I had to click it a bunch.
Great.
No smoking now.
Oh my God.
I just...
Putting three coins into piggy bank.
How many coins are there now?
Wait.
Two, three.
They fused.
Oh.
Two.
Three.
How am I supposed...
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen.
Let's see.
I killed him.
You did that very well.
So hungry.
Make something to eat?
I can make an egg.
Tada!
Delicious poached egg.
What is the minimum cuts needed to cut a circle into eight equal parts?
Four?
Three?
Is it four?
No, I tried four.
Pizza.
Mmm, pizza.
What?
Oh my God.
Have you got it?
Go to the exit.
I
know your games.
I know your games.
It's so obvious too.
So...
I knew you could do it.
Find eight animals.
One...
That guy's scary.
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Where's the eighth one?
Do you guys see it?
The toes.
Bottom right!
Stop!
I can't...
It won't let me lift the rock.
I don't think I can move anything.
Is this animal?
No?
It's not the word.
It's not behind the cloud.
Shake the tree.
Maybe if I click it a lot.
Something will happen.
Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake
Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Shake Drive the car to the road sign... What?
Huh?
What?
Oh, the clouds too!
There we go!
I thought it was a ramp.
How to eat carrots?
Thank you so much!
What?
Three numbers add up to twelve.
Oh... What's
happening?
Oh, three numbers!
I thought it was two numbers.
Use the two.
What two?
This one?
How do I use the two, though?
Three, five, six.
I'm not good at math, you guys.
Oh, wait!
Oh, oh, wait.
I don't think it's that, though.
Wait.
That doesn't add up to... Wait.
What?
Three... Six?
Three?
Small three.
Okay.
You just solved a hard math problem.
Actually, my chat did, because I don't know how to do math.
Into the box.
A magical box could hold everything.
Hup!
Oh.
Am I doing it?
Am I whacking the mole?
Oh.
Have you played whack-a-mole before?
It seems like they're insulting me.
Find the object.
This.
Okay.
I think I'm almost done with this one, you guys.
There.
The music is driving me a little... You know what?
I think I'm done.
Let's go.
Let's leave.
I think I'm done.
I think I'm good.
Okay.
Let's do...
Let's try...
Yeah.
I was going crazy from the music.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
I can't believe these are all actually playable.
That's, like, the biggest thing for me.
We gotta do the flappy foot, Jinko.
We gotta do it.
Flappy foot, Jinko.
Hey, you.
This is...
Moe...
Joe...
Joe-cito.
I shall be your coach to win the most relevant football competitions.
Do as I say.
See that little guy down there?
Just click to make him kick the ball.
Oh.
Now click again to make the ball bounce.
I'll get it.
Do I hold it?
No.
Do I drag it?
What?
I can't move it.
Can I?
No?
Click the number.
Click the ball.
Oh, spam click?
Oh!
Because it's...
Flappy ball.
You are ready to move on and play Oceana Cup.
Okay.
Go New Zealand!
Wait, why did I game over?
I looked away for two seconds.
Oh, oopsie.
Oh, he's tickling my...
Go!
I was looking at your super chest.
Oh, shoot.
Go!
Okay.
I
don't wanna... I don't wanna... It's too... You know, it's like a pretty easy, like...
To say... Oh, he...
He grabbed my...
The music's kinda awesome, though.
Oh, shoot.
I'm the... I'm good with Flappy...
Flappy ball.
How... Oh, there's Cut the Rope!
This is what you were talking about.
Wait a second.
This guy looks familiar, though.
Find the alien.
Wait...
Okay.
Cut the Rope!
Is that not like a...
An actual...
Game game?
Like a mobile game or whatever?
Classic mobile game.
I wanna try find...
I'm trying to find the one...
I wanna play the ones that are like a little weird, you know?
Find the aliens.
Okay, that's a human.
That's a frickin' alien!
Kill him!
He just wants to dance!
He just wants to have a good time!
Does this... How does this get harder?
That's my question.
Okay, level three.
I'm finding the aliens.
They're arguing in the bathroom!
With an alien!
Oh my gosh.
Skelly and alien should kiss.
What are the aliens...
Well, the aliens are doing wrong because he was arguing with her, but...
Meow, meow, meow.
Oh!
Whoa!
What?
Um...
Can't a man just be alone with his two alien girlfriends?
Can't a man just...
Can't a man just be...
Be existing with his two alien girlfriends?
Who am I to...
To...
To deny that?
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm about to kill a cop.
It's the kid.
No?
It's the guy in the suit.
Why are they angry at me?
Because I'm killing aliens?
They hate me because I...
Oh, wow!
It's the king alien!
He comes in peace.
Pitiful human!
You cannot stop the invasion!
I'll be back.
He's behind the tree.
No!
Okay, this kinda...
Wait, what's happening here?
Oh!
What?
No!
That's a mass murder!
Citizens rescued!
One...
Two...
Oh yeah, raise the roof!
Three...
Yeah, raise the roof!
Four...
Raise the roof!
Roof!
Woo!
Yeah!
Why did I capture them?
Wait, I thought I killed you earlier.
The home has been liber...
80...
86?
Holy cow!
Wow!
This game has...
Incredible...
Play value!
Incredible!
Guys, what should we end on?
What?
Should we end on?
Something really silly.
Something really crazy.
Not forking sausage again.
The family one?
You're speaking my language.
Oh, where was it?
Oh, family life.
I found it.
Let's go!
Alright.
Oh, it has my save!
Well, we just started this lady, so...
The Perez family.
We're not gonna go with some bum Tobias this time.
We're gonna...
Brianna wants to buy the lottery ticket.
It's only 10 bucks.
Brianna won a first prize of 1.09 million dollars!
You're welcome, Brianna.
Brianna feels uneasy about frequent business trips required by her job.
Resign!
Girl, we just won the lottery!
Be fully prepared.
No.
Don't quit your job.
Minky is...
It's time to transition into playing Roblox.
No!
You can't convince me.
Why did you just send me money?
Bari...
Bari, hop on YouTube Playables.
Phoebe!
Thank you for the bread!
We're playing YouTube Playable games today.
Canaan, stop laughing during your playthrough of that alien game.
I'm glad you liked it.
Bari, thank you!
Burpee, thanks for the gift and thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you.
Brianna is contemplating how to approach her work.
Work normally, girl.
You won the lottery.
Mike, thanks for one month!
Ducky, thank you so much for the gift and...
Bari, thank you for the final gift and...
Who is this?
Brianna knocked Shannon's water over at the gym.
How much does Shannon make?
Seven...
No, no, no.
Blame Shannon.
Shannon felt offended and left.
Brianna, you can do better.
We're not getting no bum this time.
Brianna and Bradford met at...
Not the basketball.
Equals!
Chat about favorites.
Stop...
Wait, no.
Play basketball together and then you'll get married.
Oh my god!
Happened!
Um...
Livestream the wedding!
Wahoo!
Kitties!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Brianna feels uncertain about her career.
Develop your own skills.
Oh yeah.
We're gonna have...
Okay, let's aim for 10 kids.
Have a baby.
The best doctor.
We're a millionaire, literally.
Wait, we got pets!
This is our baby.
Name the baby...
New names.
What if we don't get a Woody?
Would you like to play basketball with me?
I've played basketball before.
They benched me every time.
10 kids in this economy?
We're...
We're a millionaire!
Go with Aaron.
Okay, we'll go with Aaron.
Wait, what?
Wait, what do you mean?
The baby...
Wait, why does it say Alexa?
Unattractive Aaron.
It's a baby!
Wait, we have a...
We can unlock pets, apparently.
No, we can't.
We can't afford it.
I can only find 10k on the road.
Unlock after the birth of third child.
Okay, we gotta get the three babies.
Have a baby!
Best doctor.
Don't search for it online this time.
Wait, we can spend...
It's a chance.
100%.
Acquaintance doctor.
We won't lose the baby.
Yeah!
Unlock city map can purchase properties.
Whoa!
This is the city where your family resides.
This is your family's residence.
Okay.
You can assign family members to the residence.
Note that family members who are not assigned to a residence will have decreased happiness values.
Overcrowding housing will lead to a decrease...
Okay.
There you go.
Well done.
Okay.
Purchase more.
Buy commercial buildings to expand your family business.
Enjoy your game!
Uh...
What else we got in here?
I can buy the whole city.
Where were you living last time?
I think just in this house before.
Let's buy this little modest place right here.
A small diner.
Buy it.
Oh, I have to have people here.
Okay.
Bradford, you have been...
You have been reassigned.
Okay.
Emma's dad Bradford...
Oh...
Wanna give a more unique name.
Oh dear Lucy!
What...
Okay.
So we have unattractive Aaron...
And...
Happy Lucy.
Okay.
We know who the favorite is.
What about Brianna?
Brianna's happy.
Unattractive Bradford.
Unattractive Bradford says...
He wants to open a liquid...
A lick...
Lick...
Liquid...
A liquor store.
Let's...
Okay.
Let's do the 36k.
It's a...
Almost 50% chance.
There's no way we'll fail this.
No customers show up.
Damn it.
Invest in stocks!
Okay.
49% chance.
There's no way we'll fail this.
The investment failed.
Lucy likes to bite her own toes.
Moe from the Simpsons.
Yeah.
I think we gotta put chili on Lucy's toes.
Chill out little Lucy.
Lucy no longer bit her own toes.
No customer showed up to a liquor store.
I know, right?
It's pretty...
It's a dry city.
Lucy is unwilling to share her toys with other children, resulting in few friends.
Lucy is a baby.
Lucy has no friends.
Don't share toys.
Share toys.
Snatch toys for mothers.
Play alone.
Lone Wolf Lucy.
Lucy feels very lonely.
Childish Lucy.
Unattractive parents.
So sad.
Wait!
I think we can buy some more things, right?
What the?
Brianna is tough work competition.
And worries about losing the job.
Look for opportunities for promotion.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Conduct comprehensive training to increase Lucy's smart.
Why is it all just Lucy?
Let...
Let unattractive Bradford increase the charm through surgery!
This...
This game is insane!
Wait, does he have a stat of zero?
Is he zero unattractive?
Oh my god!
He's that...
That's why he's unattractive.
He has no riz or anything!
Okay, we gotta do it.
We gotta do the surgery.
Bradford walked into a world-famous plastic surgery...
Clinic.
He's now intelligent!
Gonna need a long play of this game.
No!
This is...
This is how it works.
The damn good...
Yeah.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, he's making so much more money now because he's handsome!
Brianna has been assigned to work in an unfamiliar city and feels uncomfortable.
Maybe I'll like it here.
Oh, she likes it.
Okay.
Good.
Remarried him for the money and then forced him to get surgery.
Look.
He's making so much...
He's happy now!
He's intelligent!
Has a conflict with colleagues due to differences in opinions?
I can stand that.
She is physically and mentally affected.
Are you still happy?
Happy Brianna.
Yeah, you're fine.
You're fine.
Let's have another baby.
Brianna wants to buy a lottery.
How lucky could we be to win twice?
But
like crazy, right?
Our family business, small diner, suddenly lost power.
Use a lot of candles.
Yeah, it's like a...
Oh, we use a lot of candles for lighting but business was slow.
Oh, I feel like that would be really appealing though, no?
Oh!
Like I would go...
Have you seen those like ads for like orchestras that are all...
that have a bunch of...
like orchestras by...
by candlelight?
See you later!
Romantic candlelit dinner night!
That's what I'm saying!
It wasn't the liquor store, it was our diner.
Lucy accidentally broke her parents.
Do we have a second child?
No, our ugly Erin baby is not doing anything.
I think she's broken.
Reduce Lucy's pocket money!
She's a baby!
What pocket money are we giving to our baby?
She's not even...
Throw away Lucy's toys.
We're the worst parents ever.
Gently educate Lucy.
No, Lucy you're taking your pocket money, take it away.
Lucy realized her mistake.
Lucy is like...
Lucy is five years old.
Happy Lucy has reached...
Elementary school!
Okay, everybody is going to elite private school.
Unattractive is still unattractive.
Unattractive Erin goes to the public school.
Bradford reports a poisoning...
What?
A poisoning incident in the cafeteria of her family business small diner.
Carry out a thorough investigation.
Punish Bradford!
What did he do?
We must...
Punished Bradford.
Bradford accepts the punishment and promises that such incidents will never...
What do you mean poisoning?
How did that make him ha...
It upped his...
His charm?
He's a music major.
Wow.
Oh, so is she.
Ivy League University.
Holy cow.
Brianna wants to invest in stocks.
Invest big, baby.
It paid off!
Bradford is an M.
I think so too.
Brianna is anxious about her project.
Work overtime.
You can be sad for now, but you'll get money later.
Erin often feels drowsy during class.
Work out more!
Okay, come on, girl.
Your charm is 9.
What is...
What is Lucy?
95!
Oh my god.
There's actual favorites here.
I think...
Erin needs to go to the doctor.
Why is she so sleepy?
Drink...
Erin has trouble sleeping at night and often suffers from insomnia.
Watch some Taktok before bed.
Yeah, yeah.
Erin has a harder time falling asleep.
Bradford seems to be suffering from that.
Bradford, where did you get that from?
Brad...
From where?!
I swear this game just like...
Has like a wheel of...
Of...
Illnesses you can get.
And just...
Like a database.
Fix any of them.
We gotta wait for...
We gotta just wish for a miracle Bradford.
Feels the condition is worse.
I don't think that ever...
Yields a positive result.
Yells at her.
I'm convinced that some of these options are always the same thing, you know?
Bradford found a hungry and injured dog near the flower beds!
Take it home.
We have a pet!
Wait, Bradford happily brought the pet home and spent $136 on treating its illness.
But it says plus $136, so...
Did we lose it?
No, we gained the money.
We... got the money.
Stonks.
Aaron finds her health education homework too difficult.
Giving up can be sweet.
Explore the wiki online!
Aaron has improved her learning ability and hands-on skill.
Aaron, are you still unattractive?
Yes, you are.
It's okay, we'll get you there, girl.
Oh, look at that.
Aaron is thinking about the transportation to school today.
Take a taxi, rich girl.
Spent a lot of money.
There is a hepatitis you can get from restaurants when people don't wash their hands while making the food.
It's why buffets close a lot.
What the?
That's horrible!
Money, money!
What the hell happened to Bradford?
He grew his hair out.
I'm not a fan.
I'm not... I'm not a fan.
Our family business small diner was extorted by a group of thieves!
Try to reason with the gangsters.
It's a 100% chance.
The conflict is solved and their boss promised not to bother us again.
He threatened them by giving them hepatitis.
He says, you don't want this money.
It's literal dirty money!
Aaron is...
Aaron always gets poor grades in mathematics.
Study with a friend.
Yay!
She improved her grades.
The mob fears punish Bradford.
This guy has changed.
Rihanna and Bradford feel like having another child.
Have a baby.
Yes!
Oh my god, another girl.
Unattractive, get a cute dog.
True.
Hi, I mean, don't hope you're doing well.
You too, Brandon.
Let's see.
Think of new names.
Paisley.
Mabel is cute.
We'll name the baby Mabel.
New baby Mabel.
Is that him?
Reached middle school.
Oh my gosh, $30,000.
I guess?
Okay.
Erin will also go to the elite private middle school because she just has so many issues with her grades.
It also might make her attractive.
Never mind.
Okay, never mind.
Erin was secretly watching inappropriate content online.
Girl, you just got into middle school.
Criticize and tell Erin not to do it again.
Spend $489 to buy Erin the horror movies.
What does that mean?
What are the horror movies?
Erin, girl.
She's a little freak.
By the horror movies.
Erin lost interest in them and began to consider environmental issues on her.
I guess the horror movies was like March of the Penguins.
All gooned out.
What else is she supposed to do?
She's unattractive.
Nobody else wants her, I guess.
Erin out here watching snot.
Snot's a lot.
Bradford's pet doesn't want to eat and has been throwing up.
He might be sick.
Find a veterinarian right now.
The pet is just tired.
No.
Timely treatment and recovered.
We're not gonna mess around with the pets.
How are we...
Wait, we were at 420 per second.
Now we lost mine.
Lucy is anxious about her upcoming school competition.
Practice more.
She did it.
But it went down to 386 per second.
Guys, it's 2034!
We've made it further than before!
Priyana is unhappy with the company's policies and wants to change!
Okay, it's a 68% chance of the company's current problems if we point them out.
If we do that...
And we fail, we might get fired.
And then we can't afford this lifestyle anymore.
That's upon hearing that someone is becoming a firemental activist.
Take the risk.
Priyana was fired.
Look for a new job!
Okay.
Wait, I think this pays better.
Wait, this pays better!
Sales director?
Aaron watches Burdumeck's trailer for one second and decides she's fed up with that crap.
Wait!
We're making more money now!
Bradford thinks...
We can promote our family business diner through live streaming!
Ignore his idea.
Um...
Let Bradford live stream to promote our business.
Oh gosh, Bradford wants to become a TikTok streamer.
Why do they always go to streamer?
I think Bradford's on to something.
He became happy once.
Now wants to stream?
Go Pro?
Thanks for the hilarious stream!
Wish you a speedy 400k!
I'm excited for you!
Thank you, Levin!
Thank you!
Alright, let's try it.
31% chance.
Go!
Bradford's live streaming receives no attention.
Poor Bradford.
He's gotta learn the hard way, you know.
Brianna finds small animals adorable and wants to adopt a dog.
The second dog?
Adopt from pet rescue.
Always adopt.
Everybody.
Adopt, adopt, adopt.
Oh my god, I saw the cutest cat at the pet store the other day.
Oh my gosh!
It was like...
It was the prettiest cat.
Like, it was completely white.
I've never seen such a...
It was just...
So cute!
Very cute!
Very paper mintio coated.
Have been looking to adopt recently?
Yeah!
You should, you should.
Lucy has reached the age to attend high school.
Holy moly!
$56,000 for elite private high...
Okay, we're gonna have the smartest, most attractive children ever.
Why does...
Intelligent Aaron!
Why does Aaron cost us so much more money?
So I need to suspect Bradford might be mint- Why me?
This is why I don't go into pet stores.
I had six at one point.
I think Aaron is dying.
Adjust sleep routine.
Oh!
It worked!
A rich man wants to invest in our family business small diner.
But he wants Bradford to come clean his house for him.
What?
Ask if Bradford's partner can do this for the family.
Ask if Bradford can do this for the family.
Who's Bradford's partner?
Too bad his name wasn't Chadford!
Sus.
This is kinda sus, right?
We could say no way.
Tell the rich man that he will need to pay separately for the cleanup.
Actually!
Yeah.
Bradford has a fight with the rich man who warns us to watch out.
Why?
What?
I'm confused.
Mabel has reached elementary school!
To the elite school you go.
Oh yeah.
Our family of geniuses.
Does everybody wear glasses?
What the hell?
We're a family of nerds.
Brianna has been assigned to work...
Oh yeah.
Maybe I'll lag it here.
That worked before.
Family of nerds.
Brianna plans to invest in a new company.
Invest 33k!
It was success!
Brianna's lucky.
She's a lucky owl.
Oh my gosh.
Brianna wants to go on a trip.
Guys...
It's 2037.
We've already made it?
A couple years past what we made before?
I think it's time to fly to the moon, baby.
50% chance...
To the moon!
Food!
Brianna found the footprint of Armstrong on the moon.
Oh, we're broke.
Well, no, we're not broke, but you know.
Difficulty with homework.
Ask the teachers, yeah.
We made it!
What if we didn't live?
Brianna's angry because her boss has an unreasonable task.
Request extension.
Oh, it worked!
Let's go.
Brianna is so charming.
Brianna got fired!
Because of attendance issues.
Girl, what are you doing?
Look for a new job.
Wait!
This is more money!
She's gonna be a singer.
My girl Brianna.
Wait, didn't she go to school for music?
Yeah!
Now she's a singer?
And we're making even more money?
Bradford's pet.
What was wrong with your doll?
Well, he did like get it from the street.
Yeah.
Could be...
Full of, you know.
Could have a lot of diseases.
And illnesses.
Sicknesses.
You know.
Mabel was invited by classmates to attend a weekend party.
Dress up as a clown and attend the party.
Go Mabel, go!
Mabel dressed up as a clown to attend the party and was very popular.
Oh my gosh.
It's time for university.
Intelligent Erin!
Ivy League.
She's intelligent.
Uh...
Choose...
Business.
Wait.
No.
Refresh.
Biology.
Psycho...
No.
We're a family of musicians.
Nevermind.
Choose...
You know.
Business.
Hope to develop well in the future.
Charming Lucy.
Lucy!
Can go to Public Ivy.
Or State University.
Go to State University.
You're gonna do...
Psychology.
Char...
Lucy just seems like a psychology type, you know.
You're burning through your money.
No, we're not.
We're fine.
Mabel is addicted to playing video games.
That's so true.
Spend $327 to buy Mabel the latest game.
This is how much video games will cost in 2040.
Oh my god!
Mabel loved gaming and wanted to make games in the future.
Aw!
Our little Kojima.
She's so sweet!
She's gonna grow up and make cozy gaming games.
Cozy slop.
Mabel is thinking about the transportation to school.
You know, just walk.
Mabel chose to walk and was late.
What this game has taught me is that winning the lotto can make your family do great even if they are unattractive.
Yeah, he got surgery because we were so rich.
She's gonna grow up to make family life.
Classmates think Mabel is stealing and want to frisk her?
Frisk her?
What does that mean?
What does frisk her mean?
She's in elementary school!
They want to pat her down?
Warned classmate of privacy violation.
Classmates gave up frisking Mabel but warned Mabel.
Mabel just wants to make video games.
Leave her alone.
Aaron has been arguing with parents over trivial matters.
Open your heart and talk.
Oh, it improved.
Are you still...
Oh, now she's happy!
Mabel...
Oh, it's middle school time.
I don't think you're smart enough.
We're losing money.
You just go to a private middle school.
You're fine.
Time to say goodbye.
Lucy rescued Daniel during an adventure?
Share adventure experience.
Offer comfort and support.
Wait.
Daniel actually makes money, so...
Offer comfort...
Damn, Lucy!
Yeah, what kind of adventure are we talking about?
Offer comfort and support.
They're gonna have a kid.
Have a free livestream wedding.
Wow, they're already married.
When is Lucy gonna start pulling her weight?
Why?
Why is she still a negative expense?
Oh!
I thought it said Bradford died.
Bradford's pet passed away due to old age.
No!
Aaron and Wes...
Wesley looks exactly like her father.
Give...
Aaron and Wesley met each other.
That's it.
Give Wesley a flower.
Date Wesley.
Insult Wesley.
Wesley.
Wesley also makes money, so...
We're gonna give Wesley a flower.
And...
It's so easy, you guys.
Why haven't you already fallen in love and gotten married?
All you have to do is give flowers and play basketball.
It's so easy.
It's so stinking easy.
And then you have a livestreamed wedding.
Why haven't you?
I haven't...
Played basketball or...
Received any flowers.
That's why.
I'm not good at basketball.
Make me.
Thanks for the...
Digital flower.
A kiss.
Thanks for that.
Oh...
I should...
But what about the basketball?
Oh, and also...
I have to rescue you from an adventure.
We can't forget that part too.
Have a baby.
Lucy, you need a job.
Lucy?
Barry the baby!
Wait...
No, I wanna keep Barry, please.
Please, can I keep Barry the baby?
We can have Archie the baby.
Steve...
Tommy...
Steven...
Thank you.
Oh my god, Spirity!
I have some flowers.
Will you play basketball with me?
You literally told us to play basketball growing up.
Where did you screw up?
Asking for reference.
Rajiko...
Thank you.
Aniki!
Vernon...
Oh my gosh.
Vernon Snake.
Boss...
Why you hurt me like that?
36 and maiden list still JK, by the way.
Salken...
Salken, you literally have a girlfriend!
Salken!
There!
Neo, thank you.
Panic, thank you!
In a room lit by candles full of flowers.
That sounds like a...
Fire hazard.
Teacup, thank you!
Fox, thank you.
Alright.
Lucy, you really need a job, girl.
Aaron has graduated from university!
Wait, adjust the mindset and get ready for...
To work.
Yeah, girl.
It's time to work, baby!
You stole her from me!
Virgil, thank you!
Peter!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you're being showered with...
With flowers!
It's like...
It's like I'm closing out a performance.
Lucy!
A modeling job.
She is charming, Lucy.
But I feel like we can go higher and...
Lucy is gonna become a streamer.
It's not as...
It's not as much as the model, but...
Minto, would you accept my flowers and kick my balls?
You don't kick the balls in basketball.
Ex-isi, thank you!
Does it look good?
Thank you!
Jay, thank you!
Except the job...
Charming Lucy...
Is now a charming streamer..
You guys, we're making...
Bank right now.
Aarin' Wisley are having a baby...
The baby... is... Joffrey.
Glitchfrey, thank you!
Sky Raider, thank you!
Is that what they mean by ball is life?
Raider, thank you!
Um... Joffrey.
Why is he so much more expensive than the other baby?
Oh!
Director!
$315 per second, let's go!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We are making so much money now.
Private high school.
Mabel.
Ah, thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But, thank you.
I only have basketballs.
Are we married now?
Maybe.
Oh my gosh, I thought Brianna just died too.
They're only 47 and 48.
Don't forget to buy a house.
Oh, yeah.
Vernon didn't brush his teeth properly today, resulting in bad breath.
Vernon is a baby!
Vernon...
Vernon has no teeth.
Vernon was born yesterday.
Vernon is three years old!
Actually, when do babies start getting teeth?
When do babies start having teeth?
His singular tooth.
At two.
Oh.
Way before three.
I thought they were just gummy until like five.
Only brush your teeth once.
Vernon's breath has approved, but oral problems still exist.
Don't roll your eyes at me.
Uh-oh.
Our place is really crowded.
Uh...
Oh, they're unhappy.
Upgrade!
Okay, now we're happy.
Now it's fine.
It has been a long time since you were a child.
What do you mean?
You remembered your teeth growing in!
Joffrey likes to bite his own toes.
Like mother, like son.
Gotta put them chilies on Joffrey's toes.
Joffrey cried bitterly from the spiciness of chili pepper.
It didn't work on Joffrey!
He's too stupid!
They want another baby?
Okay.
Time for more babies.
This is...
Oscar.
Oh, Oscar.
Oscar is expensive.
Why is he so expensive?
Stop getting pregnant.
Joffrey's playmate hasn't played with him recently.
Joffrey is three.
He doesn't even know what a playmate is.
Ask the playmate for a reason.
He can...
Joffrey's playmate said he is sorry.
What?
Mabel is interested in cooking.
You have no talent.
It has charm decrease.
I don't understand why.
You have no talent, Mabel.
Mabel suffered a heavy blow.
The descriptions in this game are killing me.
Oh, wait!
We can unlock something.
Brianna was favored by a rich person and received 100k.
We can...
Wait.
Unattractive Aaron?
Is she back to being unattractive?
I thought she was intelligent.
I had a dream we were cuddling last night.
What does it mean?
It means you should buy my Daki Makura.
Wait.
Forced Mabel to exercise.
No, see, it's knowledgeable Aaron.
When did she become unattractive again?
When did she become unattractive?
Brianna was made to Aaron a distant relative's will.
Holy moly, 50.
Let's do...
Let Oscar skip the growth period and become 18 years old directly.
Why only Oscar?
We'll do that once we get another baby.
Vernon saw a strong boy bullying a puppy.
Vernon is five years old.
Step forward to stop.
Vernon and the puppy defeated the other party together.
D-Dog!
Vernon's a hero!
What did he mean defeated?
This is getting intense.
Mabel dislikes doing chores.
Do chores or get beaten.
Mabel now does her chores.
Mabel's a hero.
Strong burn!
Private elementary.
Buff babies.
Yeah.
Punish snake and diamond dog.
Charming Lucy, a co-worker next to Lucy, has smelly feet.
Ask the boss to fire the colleague and it's a 100% chance.
Resign!
Patient is the key.
Send co-worker feet deodorant as gift.
I'm gonna...
We're gonna fire the person over having smelly feet.
The boss agreed with Lucy and fired Lucy's colleague.
Lucy's a streamer!
Who is Lucy's colleague?
Is she not her own boss?
Daniel found a hungry and injured dog near the flower buds in the neighborhood.
Take it home.
I kinda...
Oh my gosh, they're getting up there in age.
I kinda wanna see them die.
Happy Joffrey.
Go to private elementary school.
We're a rich family, so...
Public IV for our intelligent Mabel.
She's going to major in...
Wait, didn't she like...
Can she...
Can she do...
Can she do food?
No.
Biology.
Let them be ghosts.
I wanna see them die.
Vernon often feels drowsy.
Sleep.
He experiences an impact on his physical health and academic performance.
Uh-oh.
Oscar wants a tree house.
Oscar's five.
Build a tree house.
Give Oscar a design drawing of the tree house.
Tell Oscar not to tree.
It's true, Oscar.
It's better for you to learn when you're young.
Oscar was very disappointed.
Everybody lost happiness.
Happy Oscar.
Uh...
Private elementary.
Good job, everybody!
The boss wants Lucy to be his...
F... W... B...
Man, this is just like my childhood.
What is that?
F... W... B...
Oscar had to learn sometime.
Friends with the benefits!
Stand out and file a report.
I think...
Okay, we're gonna cause a little bit of drama.
Except...
Lucy became the boss's mistress and received a high salary and bonus.
Aaron has been replaced by someone else in her position leading in an awkward situation.
Look for opportunities for promotion.
She's a streamer who's her boss.
Vernon feels all the articles they write are terrible.
What are you doing?
Why are you writing articles?
At eight years old?
Corpo streamer.
Scary!
Copy the homework.
Read some novels.
Try to be creative, idiot.
Oh, it worked.
Just be creative, stupid.
Mabel and Wesley met at an environmental rally.
Question the environmental protection movement methods.
Share environmental protection ideas.
Wait, how much does Wesley make?
Go away, Wesley.
You're still alive!
I'm so happy!
Hello!
Oh my gosh, it's almost been four hours.
Vernon is anxious about...
Practice more.
How could you?
Wait.
Oh, come on, man.
Mabel knocked Travis's water over at the gym.
Mabel's kind of a bitch.
Blame Travis.
Travis felt offended and left.
Bien!
Mabel got in an accident with Vern.
Yeah!
I honestly admit mistake.
Try to tell a silly...
Oh, you know...
Oh...
Silly me...
Oh, did I accidentally...
Make a little...
Oh, wait...
Because it's a little accident...
Oh...
Sorry...
Tell a silly joke.
Oh!
Vern was angry and slapped him.
Damn, he slapped her!
Oh, we missed our chance.
I thought the joke would work.
Lucy and Daniel feel having another child to make their family...
Even though Lucy is a mistress?
Have the baby!
Unlock medical major in university.
Let's go.
Let's see.
A name.
Corey Stefan.
Roger.
Corey in the house.
Middle school.
Okay.
Mabel has graduated from university.
Celebrate all night with classmates.
Mabel was celebrating all night and didn't get enough sleep.
She can sleep?
Why does her happiness and everything go down?
She just got to sleep a little bit.
Oh.
Sales director.
Wait.
Is Mabel never going to find somebody now?
Oh.
Joel.
Joel makes an acceptable amount of money.
Oh my gosh.
They're playing basketball together.
It's always basketball.
It's basketball again.
I kind of want to get rid of him so that we can see another, like, encounter, you know?
Wait one second.
What?
Oh.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's get rid of him.
Joffrey middle school.
Go, Joffrey.
Go.
Oh my god.
I think the parents are going to die soon.
Mabel knocked Jonathan's water over at the gym.
Blame Jonathan.
She keeps losing her charm, though.
Her happiness is going down, too.
You'll find somebody.
Don't worry.
Joffrey.
We upgraded our home, too.
Hmm.
Joffrey was late for school again today.
Find a better...
Oh.
Wake up earlier, stupid.
Yeah.
Oscar is in middle school.
Okay.
Strong Vernon.
Always gets poor grades in physical education.
Redo.
Okay.
I want to see the parents die.
And then I think I'll end it there.
Mint.
Will Mabel ever find anybody?
Also, it rejects multiple students.
It's because I want to see a new interaction.
Unattractive Roger likes to destroy his own toys.
Tell Roger to cherish the toys.
Basketball with me?
Yeah, I'm still alive.
High school.
We can't send them to the best high school.
We've kind of blown through our...
Through our...
Lottery money.
We got a...
Another baby?
My god!
Have the baby!
My...
Wait.
Uh...
Let's see.
Another Joffrey!
Oh my gosh.
The two Joffreys can fight.
Okay, now...
We're gonna do it so Roger skips to 18 years old.
Unattractive Roger is now 18.
And he's going to university, baby!
And he's gonna be...
Physics.
Suddenly, our baby is an adult.
It's kind of crazy.
Bradford has reached retirement age and there's a job vacancy in our family business small diner.
We might face losses.
Automatically assign a successor?
Brianna is assigned to small diner.
Oh.
Okay.
That was easy.
Nepotism.
But it's his wife!
It's his wife!
Hope Lucy gets her comeuppance for cheating.
Me too!
I want to see something happen.
Hey, Joffrey!
Look how many babies we have.
Uh-oh.
Guys.
We're gonna be negative money soon.
Nepo wife, true.
Wiki!
Nice.
Wikipedia worked.
Huh!
Maybe it's a basketball.
It's a basketball again.
It's always gotta be basketball!
These kids need jobs.
Lucy is the one with three kids.
Mm-hmm.
Playing slot for four hours.
Hey!
Yeah, that's me.
Reynaldo.
Reynaldo and Mabel.
Wait, now Brianna.
Brianna, you just got assigned.
Okay.
Aut- Automatically assign a successor.
Middle-aged Wesley.
He looks just like her dad.
She?
Oh, stop, stop.
Daniel's pet passed away.
That's so sad.
Erin married someone that looks exactly like her father.
I just want to let you guys know that.
Like, actually.
A hundred- This is the same exact little model.
Vernon brought a classmate home with him.
Ooh.
Ignore it.
Vernon had a pleasant day with his classmate.
I like how it's like, ignore it.
Like, ignore the creature.
That just came into our apartment.
Or our home.
Joffrey!
Snatched the toys from others.
Joffrey gets along worse with kids after taking their toys.
Joffrey's a little shit.
Childish Joffrey.
No, we can't have any- No, Mabel, sorry.
It's not a good time.
We can't have any more babies.
Lucy is sucking us dry.
The family wants to go camping.
Go camping on Mars with a budget of- What?
Wait, but I want to see the parents die.
Wait, the boss too?
No, these are the children.
With what budget?
If we go into the red, you guys...
I won't be able to see the parents die.
Can you save, Scum?
I don't think in this game.
A budget of what?
Take me to Mars, Mito.
I am getting tired, though.
Let's see it.
Let's see what happens.
Our family members successfully landed on Mars.
Looking at the scene before them, they felt everything was unbelievable.
Alright, let's see.
Camp on Mars.
No, can't do that.
Mito, it's a little P-Flix fire.
Let's see if there was a money loss.
Oh.
We just were able to do that.
Vernon will go into medical.
Free trip to Mars, baby.
Roger graduated.
Tearing up all his books.
Roger tore up his books, feeling much more relieved.
Fox, thanks for the gifted.
Thank you.
The boss paid for it.
Ah.
No, no baby, Mabel.
No baby, no baby.
Wait.
Daniel and Rinaldo look the exact same.
Oh my gosh.
Happy Joffrey.
Going to school.
Another.
It's two happy Joffreys.
This happy Joffrey will choose music, just like his grandpappies.
Stop getting pregnant.
Roger found the joff...
No.
Refresh.
Driver.
Is it because you're unattractive, Roger?
Is that why you can't get paid well?
Receptionist.
Rider.
You know I'll take that.
Rami, thanks so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
As long as you're making some money, you know.
Everybody else...
Who is this?
Oscar, why are you costing me almost $450 per second?
Wesley reports a poisoning incident.
Punish, Wesley.
Oscar is going to a public ivy.
We're going to do philosophy.
You don't have a real career.
YouTube playable called Family Life.
That's this.
Why is punishment work so well?
I don't know.
Joffrey is anxious.
Practice more, buddy.
I need these parents to die style.
Fine.
Have the baby.
I don't care.
Search for it online.
Oh.
She didn't have...
She lost the baby.
Roger and Samantha.
How much do you make, Samantha?
Damn!
Give Samantha a flower.
And now they're married.
And before they live to $100.
Because they're...
They're dang rich.
They only make $35 per second.
Brendan and Layla.
How much does Layla mean?
Oh, Layla.
Goodbye, Layla.
We need someone more than 80 bucks.
You know?
Hannah!
Basketball.
Play basketball together.
I was trying to wonder how they do this punishment.
Mateo, thank you so much for the 20 gift.
Thank you.
I wish I could skip forward faster.
Faster, faster.
Oh, I paused it on action.
Die, parents.
Die.
He's almost 70.
Elderly Bradford.
A baby already?
We are making more money.
No.
I don't want to upgrade our home.
It's so ex...
It's 100k!
It's a upgrade!
We can't.
Our diner only makes 72 bucks.
Oh, now it makes even less.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Raynaldo, get in there.
How much does it make now?
190.
There we go.
Joffrey!
First, Joffrey.
Oh my gosh.
You guys spend so much dang money.
Joffrey was asked to give a speech.
Give a speech on environment...
Why are they so obsessed with environmental issues?
I have...
A dream.
Average your hands and welcome to membership.
And...
I feel guys welcome to membership.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
I have a dream.
Everyone thought Joffrey had a promising future.
Let's quit dreaming while you're ahead, says...
Says Oscar over here.
Oscar, graduate and get ready for work, buddy.
You...
You need to work more than anybody else.
You are making nothing.
I, too, had a dream.
Except, take whatever you got.
Take it.
Please.
We need the money.
He's 70 years old.
He's gonna die.
Who's Quinn?
Quinn!
Quinn makes no money.
No.
Insult Quinn.
Get her out of here.
Quinn scolds and screams at Vernon before leaving.
And Vernon spends...
$163...
$1,000 on therapy.
I can't.
Just be a driver, man.
Just do it.
$1,600.
Not therapy.
It's insane.
Guys, I'm so tired.
I just want this...
These parents to die.
Joffrey, you got the job.
Oh my gosh.
We're making so much money.
Judge not by the color of their skin, but the content of their skin.
What are their bones like?
Yeah.
They're...
They're in...
Insides.
Okay, you guys can finally have a baby.
We have little...
Salvador.
Little Salvador here.
Okay, Joffrey.
Joffrey.
Delicious bones.
Bones, bones.
We need more bones.
We need a bone.
Joffrey encountered a robbery.
Beg for mercy.
Call the police.
You're not going to be so happy anymore, Joffrey.
Beg for mercy.
Oh, I guess it worked.
I guess that, uh...
Worked.
Cool.
A baby.
Okay, have a baby.
Little baby...
Let's see.
Amelia!
Little baby Amelia.
Why
were they, like, looking at her?
Like that.
Got into an accident with Sofia.
Oh, no.
Silly joke.
Slapped Oscar.
Oof.
A child already?
No, no, no.
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
The house is now crowded.
Okay, we gotta upgrade.
We just lost 100k, but that's alright.
Ami!
Rinaldo is interested in an employee under our family.
Wait.
Rinaldo...
Handsome Rinaldo.
Rinaldo with a wife.
Rinaldo who just had a baby.
Rinaldo who has a baby that's four years old.
Date the employee.
Nothing happens to them when you do that.
Vernon recently went through a breakup and feels sad every...
No, he didn't.
When did he go through a breakup?
How long have you been playing BitLife for?
This is my first time ever.
Beers!
More beers!
Vernon is greatly affected physically and mentally.
Vernon is our only single...
Oh, no.
Oscar's also single.
Oscar kind of sucks.
No, baby.
Beer o'clock, baby.
They're also getting old.
Joffrey lacks self-confidence.
That is your own problem.
Joffrey feels very unsure about herself and is emotionally unstable.
Wait.
Herself?
Joffrey cries and refuses to go to school every day.
Um...
Rewards.
Joffrey has increased his motivation.
No baby.
Oh, we do have room.
Salvador.
Going to a school.
Joffrey has reached the age...
Okay.
You know what?
You're not going to go to university, Joffrey.
He didn't like studying that much anyway.
You're plenty happy.
Oh, see?
You didn't even need to go to school.
You've got a job paying more than some of these other people.
Had a hard time in society.
No baby.
The only thing about this game is there's so much...
That is, like, so repetitive, you know?
Pretend nothing happened.
What the...
Oscar, please.
Oscar.
He died.
Bradford's children wants to send Bradford to the nursing home.
Refuse.
Bradford's children no longer keep in touch with Bradford.
Bradford.
Wait.
When they want to send it...
When they want to send Brianna, we can...
We can condemn them.
Sadford.
No baby.
Vernon and Layla.
Layla has no job.
Fine.
Whatever.
Fine, Layla.
Get a job.
A baby?
You have no job.
You costing me $178 per second.
You think money grows on trees?
Lana.
And now they're married.
All you have to do is accept your mistake.
Even if you have an accident, you accept your mistake and then you get married.
Guys, marriage is so easy.
Argo, thank you for the thank you.
Thank you.
It's so easy.
It's so stinking easy.
Mabel is in a tough work competition.
How much do you make?
Develop your own skills.
You got this.
He's getting up there in age.
No baby.
He's getting up there.
The diner lost power.
Check the circuit and repair.
Oh, it worked.
They're handy, man.
Handy, handy.
No baby.
Lana passed away due to old age.
She died first!
We can have...
We can leave it to the state.
Basic funeral.
Standard funeral.
Luxury.
Rihanna's funeral will be carefully planned.
What do you mean minus two happiness?
You're dead!
Leave it to the state for you, Bradford.
The state cremate the body of Bradford.
How is his happiness?
I don't think his health is 24.
His health is zero.
Well...
That was anticlimactic, wasn't it?
This was a lot of fun, guys.
I didn't expect to be playing these games for four hours.
But I also just was like...
I also knew I haven't been doing so many long streams lately.
And I just kind of really wanted to hang out a lot.
So this was fun!
Dune is about a secret order of women doing this for thousands of years in order to breed a man.
And he's so in tune with his feminine side that he can see the future.
That's...
Neat.
Thanks, man.
Thank you!
This was fun.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the silly stream.
Also, happy long weekend for everyone in Canada.
Happy long weekend.
I know this was a long stream too, so...
Everybody.
Do it good.
Thank you.
Rose, for you.
Balls are for throwing at the babies to repel them.
Great.
So good, thanks for the ticket.
Thank you.
So basketball together.
Basketball.
Same time next week.
Thank you guys.
Refusatory.
Thank you.
I saw the start and took a nap and saw the end.
Nice nap.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
See you guys later.
Bye-bye.